e
e e
it really was bad this morning on the
roads good morning everybody uh the
education funding committee is going to
commence here with our executing uh some
of the first bills which we exec this
year and the um first bill which we're
going to have on 193 is one where I'm
going to be making a motion so I'm going
to pass the B gavl off to our vice chair
and he's going to have the experience of
chairing the first Bill thank you for
that experience okay I'm going to open
the executive session on HB 1993 and
recognize representative lad for a
motion yes I'd like to make a motion on
193 which is a bill relative to the
maximum number of credits per course
eligible for the Dual and concurrent
enrollment program of O OTP okay do I
see a
second representative luno
seconds and would you like to speak uh
to your bill representative lad uh yeah
just very very briefly this bill is uh a
bill which really
clarifies that we will have courses not
exceeding four credits and it's been put
forth by the community college system
and uh and we have some course of course
could be as much as 12 credits and that
we we don't want to go that direction so
that's I guess all I will say on
that okay i' recognize representative
Earth for a motion thank you Mr chair is
it yeah okay thank you I would like to
you should go to the second verse he did
oh oh yeah you let him speak no he
doesn't need to speak now no no I can do
you want to yes I'd love to just just a
couple words
I think um with this bill it um it
continues toh to provide an excellent
opportunity for high school kids to um
to uh take part in dual and concurrent
enrollment classes and ear earn college
credit um before they graduate from high
school and um and enter with a good uh
you know Headway into their higher
education okay thank you then
representative Earth thank you Mr chair
I'd like to make a motion to the bill uh
motion number I think we all have this
in front of us it's number two motion to
amend motion to amend the bill you can
see in finance we don't have to do these
quite so directly um amendment number
d02 which I think we all have in front
of us that yep 0200 H 0200 H have right
there and it does one thing it replaces
section two
and all it's doing is changing the
effective date uh to make it on passage
and this was a request of uh
ccsnh very good thank you for the motion
second by representative
luno uh any uh commentary further
discussion okay seeing none um you want
to speak no I'd like to make a
motion I think we have to first vote on
the motion on the amendment so um with
no further comment I'm going to ask the
clerk to call the
role would you show hands on you can do
that on Amendment okay since it's an
amendment can we do a show of hands
without objection all those in favor
raise your
hand appears to be unanimous all those
opposed just to be
sure none we're a full Committee of 18
today so that's 18 to Zer on the
amendment okay and now I'll recognize
representative flad for a further motion
yes thank you Mr chair I'd like to make
the recommendation of otpa on HB
193 second by representative Damon thank
you both any further discussion no I
have no further discussion okay so the
motion on uh the table is uh
otpa on House Bill 193 as amended by uh
Amendment
00h and uh if there's no further comment
I call the clerk to take the
role you it l no you I I go last I go
last
yes sorry representative spillsbury
yes representative Maguire yes
representative F yes representative
kofalt yes representative kcam yes
representative
kovich yes representative Brown yes
representative Megan yes representative
Wier and for representative peoples yes
represent luno yes represent James yes
representative Burton yes representative
fellow yes representative Damon yes
representative Richie yes representative
kitan yes representative
winstein yes and representative lad
yes total 18 yay zero
nay okay the votes okay being 18 in
favor and nonone opposed uh the bill
passes as amended and uh I'm no no it is
it okay to put in consent yes exact
exactly where I'm heading ask yes course
it's
automatically so without objection uh we
can place this on the consent calendar
seeing no objection it will go on
consent um I'd like to just add now this
is the first bill we've done and the
person who makes the motion is the
person that has the right the committee
report we often times call that the
blurb and that's oldfashioned language
but there's a lot of us around here that
understand it as the blur I have and we
have here in the committee a template
which is used to do that with it's a
Microsoft Word document where it it say
The Format is such it comes from our
administrative assistant and from the
folks upstairs so I'm going to email
that to everybody here so you have a
copy of this document so if you're
making a motion and you're having to get
that report language to me you know so
that I can read it over and then send it
on its way uh to the to the clerk and to
the speaker of the house for their
review then it will be on the same
format that we do it in and and it's
easy for the administrative system just
copy paste what you submit right into
the calendar report so that's coming to
all and I I'll get that out somewhere
today to you
so so I'll take the gavel back and we'll
go on to the next bill it's HB
295 this is making School building Aid
programs funds
non-aps and I will look at look to uh uh
representative spillsbury for a motion
thank you Mr chairman I move uh that we
retain HB
295 I'll second
that okay we have a motion on the floor
to retain 295 made by representative
spillsbury second by representative luno
representative spillsbury would you like
to speak to your motion uh yes thank you
very briefly uh we have several bills on
building Aid they're complex raise
issues that we need to give more
attention to and we can better do that
if we hold them into the
fall represent luno he's good any
further discussion from the committee on
this bill HB
295 not seeing
any Madam clerk when you're ready we're
ready now you don't ever have to rush on
this this take time okay sure bar sha
was always quick to tell us slow it
down no pressure no pressure so the
motion is to retain representative
spills Berry yes representative Maguire
yes representative F yes representative
kofalt yes representative kcom yes
representative
Popovich yes representative Brown yes
representative mhan
representative McKagan yes
representative wer yes representative
luno yes representative Ames yes
representative Burton yes representative
fellows yes representative Damon yes
representative
bridie yes representative
cran and representative Weinstein
yes 18 yes got to go to the top oops and
representative lad
yes so total 18 Y and no zero
n okay now this is a a bill which is
being retained there will not be a
committee report we keep it in our
committee and uh we work on
it next bill which question yes um uh
question for the chair can a can a bill
um such as House Bill two where we 295
retained in committee could that still
be acted on during this first year what
we would do is we will hold a building
Aid Bill one we may have and we see and
we have work sessions if we see parts of
any one bill which are good you just we
amend it to the other so we don't have
multiple building Aid Bills going
through okay so it still could come out
this this the concept yeah or that yeah
that language could be parked in another
bill terrific thank you yes you're
welcome the also the order in which you
see these bills coming to you is not for
those that are new not necessarily the
order which we always we can jump around
we're executing bills we can take any
particular bill in any order and so the
next bill which I will look at order
right here is HB 354 and I'm not going
to bring that bill up for exec today
seeing I've had communication from the
Department of Education with others
there are some potential changes we may
have to really filter into this bill
before we move forward with it I don't
like to send forward crummy legislation
we need to make sure that we got all our
policy issues dotted eyes dotted and
te's crossed so we're not going to take
action on 354
today so the next bill is HB
366 School building Aid eligible
projects
and I would like to recognize uh
representative spillsbury for a motion
thank you Mr chairman I move uh that we
retain HB
366 I'll second
that represent spillsbury the maker of
the motion do you have anything else to
say on this no simply that for the same
reasons that we're retaining HP 295 I
suggest we do that as well okay
represent luno concur Concur and any
further discussion from the
committee Madam
clerk representative spillsbury
yes representative Maguire yes
representative F yes representative
kofalt yes representative kcom yes
representative Popovich yes
representative Brown yes representative
M
mahagan yes Pres wer yes representative
luno yes representative Ames yes
representative Burton yes representative
fellows yes representative Damon yes
representative
bridie yes Ricky thank you
sorry representative
cran representative Weinstein yes
representative lad yes
so we have 18 y zero
Nays any problem consent then we should
Park that one there as well oh excuse me
right that's right we're raining not
okay next bill we have is 494 and this
is relative to the math learning
communities program and making an
appropriation therefore and I'm going to
hand the gavel off to representative
spillsbury thank you I'm opening the
executive session on HB 494 and I'm
recognizing uh representative lad for a
motion yes thank you very much I'd like
to make the motion OTP on
494 relative to the math learning
communities program Z
second second by representative
Luna would you like to speak to your
motion um I think we're all pretty much
familiar with the math learnings
community so uh I have nothing further
to say
okay representative
Luna representative Luna all set okay
and representative F thank you Mr chair
I like to make a
motion
yes may I pass it around first so
everybody has a
copy please take a moment while the
copies are being
circulated they
come thank you
[Music]
I'm going to wait till everyone has a
copy of the amendment
okay representative Earth uh did you
second it yeah let's see well you're
you're going to make a motion make your
motion um so i' like to move amendment
number
2025-the thank you Mr chair
so we have a rather
tight potentially a budget season coming
up and as such this original bill the
bill as without the amendment is
requesting additional funding for this
program and given the current situation
while I'm support of of both the bill
and the funding as it is um in
recognition of the tight uh funding
situation I would suggest that we flat
fund this uh the same the math learning
program um over the next
biennium um at this point in time this
bill will come back through finance
committee um specifically division two
which coincidentally I sit on and at
that time we should have a better a
clear understanding of our Revenue
picture uh as the Ways and Means
Committee the house Ways and Means Comm
committee will have reported out their
expectations for our revenues over the
next bium uh and at that point we can
consider
whether we have the funds to um go
further with
this at that point
thanks second yeah um thank you very
much Mr chair yeah I I think a lot of us
have heard it's going to be a very
difficult um um budget uh uh season this
year and I think this is a it's a little
bit of a tough Bill tough pill to
swallow uh reducing the math learning
communities by $100,000 over the um over
the bium but uh but I think given the
situation before us um uh it makes sense
and um and support the amendment thank
if I could just clarify uh am I correct
U representative Earth the only change
that the amendment makes is to adjust
from
250,000 to 200,000 for the second year
of the banian well just for the second
so so so pardon me it's $50,000
reduction it's 200200 for the two so by
leveling I got it right then you said
100 it's 100,000 total no because the
change the change that the amendment
makes year $250,000 you're a math Wiz
now just a clarify the change that the
amendment makes to the bill is a net
$50,000
okay all right everyone satisfied and
just clarify what that represents that
represents the same as the current the
term we're in now budgeting it's
identical very good are there further
comments yes i' like to add some further
comments on this seeing that as the
prime sponsor this bill math learning
communities this is a very very
important bill in in a way for the
community college system work closer
with our high schools regarding the
performance of our high school students
in ter terms of mathematics and ensuring
that uh the the concepts the principles
and all associated with algebra 2 are
accomplished and we maybe we change
learning styles teaching styles around a
little bit to get this done but there's
a real healthy uh bill but what we also
have be cognizant and the message is
going off to those that are in finance
right here right now that this bill is
not just allocating dollars it's
allocating a change in policy so the
bill itself is change from what you see
underneath that chapter a chapter law
right now for the math learning
communities program so um to move this
you know the amount forward yes you say
for the math learning communities
program but you also have to move
forward the policy statements here the
structure and organization and how this
is presented and how it's worked with
those schools in terms of professional
development all that that's addressed in
this bill so I encourage the you know
the
the whole nine yards to move forward
later are there further comments on the
amendment seeing none uh will the clerk
please call the role on the amendment
0172 show of hands Works yes okay all
those in favor raise your hands we doing
this very good appears unanimous anybody
opposed none 180 on the amendment thank
you for the shortcut
okay so that brings us back to um a new
motion representative lad yes I'd like
to make make the motion excuse me for
this bill uh HP 494 as
otpa with the amendment that we just
addressed otpa with Amendment
0172 second representative Damon
seconds okay now any further comment on
the bill as amended none from the make
of the motion the second very good
seeing none we have the motion in the
second representative Damon seconded and
asked the clerk to call the
role representative spillsbury yes
representative Maguire yes
representative F yes representative
copal yes representative kcom yes
representative popovic yes yes
representative Brown yes representative
mahagan yes representative Wier yes
representative luno yes representative
Ames yes representative Berton yes
representative fellows yes
representative Damon yes representative
Ricky yes representative
kitan representative Weinstein
yes representative lad
yes 18 years and zero nay so the vote is
18 in favor none opposed on uh HB 494 is
amended and uh if there is no objection
we can place that on the consent
calendar seeing none this will go on
consent I return the gavl thank you uh
next bill we have on the dock is HP 515
this is repealing the Charter Public
School eligibility for state school
building
Aid thank
you my trusted advisor has uh said that
because that's a spending bill it won't
go on consent it'll be on the regular
calendar um but Mr
if I'm not mistaken under two under
$10,000 does not have to go on is not
required to go onto the regular count
that was two under Grand each year of
the banum but
it's it it change doesn't change it
doesn't change from what we've done in
previous years I believe it
represents new spending for the coming
bium and therefore I I yeah yeah okay
I'm glad we're taking time to S this out
but I do believe therefore it has to go
on the regular
calendar
yeah all righty back to
515 this is an act repealing the Charter
Public School eligibility for state
school building Aid and like to
recommend uh recognize represent
papovich Miller for a papovich Miller
for a motion please thank you Mr chair
I'm making a motion of inexpedient to
legislate on HB
515 yes sir
second second represent McGuire makes a
second uh represent papovich would you
like to speak to your motion yes Mr
chairman I'll be very brief charter
schools are public schools there is no
valid reason to treat them differently
in regards to school building Aid this
bill suggests that we should treat
charter school students as second class
citizens it's bad policy and should be
rejected thank you R
mire I agree further discussion yes
represent luno so thanks very much Mr
chair um I disagree with the the motion
of itl here uh I think there is a very
distinct difference between um charter
schools and public schools uh for
example public schools
are governed by a publicly elected
school board and charter schools are not
charter schools are Incorporated in New
Hampshire as private non nonprofit
corporations public schools are not and
over the uh the two decades is that
we've had charter schools in New
Hampshire we've seen something like 20%
of them go insolvent due to um Financial
mismanagement um uh and fraud so so um I
think it would be premature to
to invest our limited State resources
into um into building aid for for
Charter Schools given the fact that they
are not the same as public schools and
are in fact are very different than
public schools uh from uh from both a
governance standpoint and from a um from
uh you know uh
and whether or not the state should uh
should invest its its money in them it's
also very unclear from from uh Charter
School founding documents whether any
have um have any sort of
dissolution uh uh
standards that would put the state in a
position where it would get its any of
its um uh money back should uh should
another Charter School uh receiving
building Aid go belly up thank you
further discussion representative
Damon thank you Mr chair I will also be
voting against the itl for the reasons
that representative luno uh reported and
also although we call them Charter
Public Schools they do not have to
follow statutes in regards to Public
Schools tools unless it is specifically
stated in the statute that Charter is
included which I think is a common
misconception so they do not have the
same standards um I will say they there
may well be some very well operating
good Charter Schools but overall funding
infrastructure when we have so
little we're completely inadequate in
school infrastructure funding adding
this to it does not make
sense further discussion from the
committee
not seeing
any we'll call The Madam clerk we're
going to call the the role the motion is
itl on the charter school
[Applause]
bill got to get the number
here5 on
5:15 relative to repealing the Charter
of school eligibility for the school
building aid
program rightl representative spillsbury
yes representative wi yes representative
F
yes representative kofalt
yes representative kcom
yes representative
popovic
yes representative Brown
yes representative mahagan
yes representative wer
yes Representative luno no
representative Ames
no representative Burton
no representative fellows
no representative Damon no
representative bricky absolutely not
representative
cran representative Weinstein
no representative lad yes
so total vote there are 10 yes and eight
no so the motion passes and it will go
on the regular
calendar representative Damon will do a
minority represent Damon will do the
Minority Report and represent papovich
will do the majority report uh I'd like
to have those reports to me by tomorrow
noon so we can get these on to the next
docket so next session docket so uh both
of you please be cognizant of that that
deadline that and I you can use to that
template which we have that'll be sent
which I will send immediately on this
being done done by noon Yeah by noon
tomorrow tomorrow tomorrow
okay okay we have another bill which
we're dealing with this after this
morning and this is 8 HB
716 uh HB 716 uh makes an appropriation
for the Dual and concurrent enrollment
program and I would like to hand the
gabble over to represent spelsbury thank
you Mr chairman so I'm going to open the
executive session on
hb76 and recognize representative lad to
make a motion yes I like to make a
motion of OTP on HB 716 I'll second that
seconded by representative luno okay
representative flad would you like to
speak to the motion yes I would uh this
is another Bill thank you Mr chair that
speaks to the community college system
and they're working with the schools
with concurrent which is courses taught
at the high school and dual enrollment
which is done at the facility of the
community college system this has been a
very very very successful program with
students that are in high school having
the opportunity to receive college
credit for the courses that are taught
by an individual that has a master's
degree and and and professional
background in the subject area being
taught and is able to teach it to the
standards that are acceptable to the
accrediting organization at the uh
college system uh it was a program set
up to where we'd fund these courses
at150 bucks a
course and we have a a an allow of how
many courses one can take in grades 10
11 or 12 and if a student wants to take
more courses Beyond what's in statute
it's on the student to pay that
difference however what we've seen from
this program by having this
program rather than having these
students take these college courses
after they graduate where the cost for
the courses which are done during those
high school years will save the students
and families over $10 million this is a
wonderful savings to those and one of
the goals we had in the governor's task
force last year was to deal with this
issue of affordability and accessibility
this program does both of those so I
would encourage uh the folks to you know
go along with the motion of
OTP thank you U representative luno
would you like to add any comments no
thanks all set representative B
recognized for an amendment thank you Mr
chair um I can well let me pass it
around first I make any
motions okay again we'll pause while the
amendment circulated
this back we
right
yeah okay everybody has a copy
representative RSE uh would you make
your motion I'd like to make motion
d16h to Bill number HB
716 I'll second that seconded by
representative luno and representative F
please speak thank you Mr chair so this
is the same in the same vein as the
previous motion that I made this is
another program that's funded outside of
CC ccsnh H's budget and it's an ongoing
program which I fully support and I
fully support the goal of increasing the
uh amount budgeted which is what's in
the current bill but again given the
current situation I think better wiser
if you will to Flat fund this at the
same rate as we're in the current bium
so that's what this does the $2 and5
million per year is the same as the two
and half million dollar per year in the
current um bium
very good so the change that the
amendment makes to the bill is to reduce
by 500,000 in both years of the grip
Center Flo yeah thank you Mr chair um I
I have a question to to ask and and
possibly um um the um the representative
from the community college system might
um Shannon might have the answer to this
but just wondering um in um in going
from $3 million a year which is from the
bill to2 half million do a year what
does that mean for um for students who
want to take um early college classes I
mean are we going to are we going to be
limited we you you can feel if it's a a
question which is relevant to and we
have technical support you can get that
technical support okay
Shannon if you have something you can
add that would be helpful this is good
time thank
Youk thank you Mr chair thank you
Shannon good morning thank you for the
question I'm Shannon Reed with the
community college system of New
Hampshire um first of all I appreciate
the committee's consideration of of flat
funding this at this stage in order to
you know keep it moving forward
understanding that division 2 will
probably have a um more um a look at it
later in the process when perhaps more
is known about Revenue But to answer
your question I I think that certainly
um there's a potential that this would
limit enrollment or at least limit the
the number of courses that are funded
through the state students can certain
take more at their own expense um but
again um we we do what we stretch that
appropriation as much as we can and um
we certainly hope that as the process
evolves through the rest of the session
that we may have a chance to revisit the
total
amount so so just a just a followup on
that yes follow yeah thank you very much
Mr chair and thank you very much shann
um so so when when cutting half when
reducing half a million so bringing it
back to um to what what what what we
currently have um funded so $500,000 in
in each year and courses at Community
colleg I I think are around are they
still 215 a
credit and so a two or three credit
course would be around a
$650 thing minus the 150 that the
student pays leaves 500
so reducing it by $500,000 would
potentially limit a th000 students from
taking a three credit so that's a that's
pretty fast math for me sitting up here
um is that generally how the math works
for this we offer these courses to high
school students at a discount already
they're $150 per course so I I don't
think that the calculation you laid out
is quite what we'd see um this the
course the cost of the students is $150
the program picks up that cost covers
that cost but if the students have to
take additional courses they're still
paying $150 they're not paying the full
cost that they would if they were um
college students yeah so I'm missing
something on that so the programs
picking up the 15 or the programs
picking up the difference between what
the student pays the 150 and what the
community colleges would normally charge
our agreement in the statute is that we
charge for the courses that are offered
in the high schools we charge 100 $50
right regardless of the funding source
so this program with the
funding pays the $150 tuition cost that
the students would pay but if the
students have to take a course without
the funding from the state they would
still pay $150 does that answer question
it's a little different M only goes
towards so there's really no cost to the
student right there no cost to the
student of courses that are covered by
the by the program there's no cost to
okay thank
you okay representative glad would you
like to add to that yeah I'd like to
just CL thank you very much Mr clarify
some of this discussion the the cost
which we're looking at if you were out
of college or out of high school would
be up at a level like that but because
we negotiated back Years with Ross catel
who at that time was the chancellor and
this is why you don't see the university
system as part of that at that time
Chancellor leech was not willing to go
along with the 150 but the Community
College saw the gains that in the
affordability issues with students
accepted it and that's where we're we
we're held to that right now the other
issue which we have is that since we put
this program in place for grades 11 and
12 initially it's been expanded to
grades 10 11 and 12
that then now says oh there's more
students involved in the program and we
have had legislation where it's up to
four courses but then we couldn't offer
four courses to every kid that was
wanting to take the four courses simply
because we had more kids in the program
and so we had to cut it back and up to
well up to went to about two courses or
thereabouts as I recall Shannon so um
the the $3 million is an effort to try
to move to have uh be able to afford in
in appropriate dollars which would meet
all those students potentially that
would be wanting to take concurrent and
dual enrollment uh however this is the
figure which is uh seen by in the budget
from the previous year and with the
hardship we have uh as as the community
college system has mentioned as
represent F has mentioned this moves it
forward and I'm hoping that if you see
any additional dollars that are are
available at the division 2 level or
Finance level that this be one of those
areas that we see as a real priority
issue and and that was a it's coming
forth as a result of the governor's task
force and hp1 1450 which we passed last
year thank
you yes representative Damon thank you
Mr chair so my remarks
are coming from my experience as a
person person who benefited from a very
similar program in another another state
when I was in high
school
and making college courses affordable
and accessible especially to students
who might not have the confidence to
believe that they were higher ed
material is incredibly value valuable I
think it also is marketing our New
Hampshire higher education
systems and potentially therefore down
the line keeping kids in New Hampshire
as part of our
Workforce so my question is to the
colleagues here on this committee who
are also in
finance I'm worried that respecting our
fiscal challenges this
year if we pass this amendment what is
the probability that finance will rather
than increasing it reduce it
further have we already negotiated down
or to I know you can't make promises but
i' just like to hear some thoughts on
that
representative um I can't give you odds
at this point since we don't even have a
Topline number uh you know in worst case
as I explained to um ccsnh and also to
UNH there's a possibility of cutting
their funding not just this but the
actual funding to the to the to
universities so until we really have
those numbers some ways and means so
that we know what it is we're shooting
for it's really hard I mean obviously I
really I'm very sport of of both these
programs just when in the math learning
program they're excellent programs as
everybody here has has stated and
certainly if we have extra funds it
wouldn't be much of a stretch to add
both of these um back in but at this
point we really don't have any idea
other than we've seen um revenues going
going down to date um we haven't got we
don't even have the governor's numbers
at this point in terms of what she's
projecting for
um for a budget um but certainly I'm
very supportive and I think in general
our committee certainly our subcommittee
is very supportive and and I think in
general the finance committee is very
supportive of both these programs as
representative lad has
stated representative Pap P Miller a
very brief addition besides obviously
agreeing with everything that was just
said if you look at the track history of
division 2 and ccsnh I think that you'll
find that we greatly value their
contributions and we find them to be a
you know great addition to everything we
can do in the state and we will do
everything that we can to fund this you
know ideally to the original levels it's
just at this point in time that's not
something we could promise thank you I
have one last comment and representative
flad um yeah we talk about accessibility
and affordability but we also have
another term
transferability and the what we're
seeing as a result of this program more
students are getting involved in this
type of program at the high school level
once they're hooked and they take the
bait they are now going to potentially
go on through the college systems and
the university system because these
courses are transferable not to every uh
uh program at let's say UNH or Keen or
Plymouth however we have over a 100
Pathways now that we have worked on in
1530 which was a bill which
drove the point across that we want a
student taking a course at this level
and having some kind of a guarantee that
it's going to apply to later on so they
don't have to take you know another
course to do what they already have done
that's a costly Affair so there's a lot
lot to this and it there's also
potentially Workforce issues as a result
60% of our high school grads we're going
outside this state for Education if we
can hook them up in the community
college system that is the key and
that's what Chancellor Rubenstein is
trying to drive home and so I would
encourage if there's any Buck anywhere
and I I know you the finance people are
here they're hearing it and they've
always been positive towards the
community college system so thank you
very
much representative
Ames this has been a great discussion
and uh helpful to me as I've learned
more about this program I think that uh
I'm hearing a consensus that uh we we
prefer not to be be reducing this number
in the text of this bill but um given
the circumstances it's a prudent thing
to do um I hope that the report on our
action makes clear that if the money is
available at the time of the uh budget
making process that uh this would be one
of the first uh to get returned to the
number uh in this original
Bill thank you representative Ames well
the sentiment certainly seems um
broad um and I think we can we can amend
the bill and still report it out
enthusiastically okay seeing no further
comments uh on the amendment
I'm going to ask the clerk to call the
role
on thank you again we have an amendment
we can shortcut so all those in favor
please show uh by raising your
hand appears unanimous any
opposed none 180 thank you thank
you okay so that brings us back to the
uh original motion is amended
representative lad
I'd like to make a motion OTP on 716
which is making the appropriation for
the duel and concurrent enrollment
program and the amendment which we're
amending otpa is
H second from representative Damon
discussion okay seems we've all had a
chance so uh with no discussion we'll
call the role on otpa
representative spillsbury
yes representative Maguire yes
representative F yes representative
kofalt yes representative gcom yes
representative popovic yes
representative Brown
yes representative mahagan
yes representative Wier yes
representative luno yes representative
Ames yes
representative Burton yes representative
fellows yes representative Damon yes
representative bricky yes representative
kitan yes representative Weinstein yes
and chairman lad
yes
180 yes Zer you got Mr chair yeah I
realize that usually sponsor writes the
report but I'd be happy to write it if
you'd like to but how about we declare
the result of this so
yeah the vote being 18 to0 uh the otpa
motion on HB
716 as amended is passed and and I
taking the gamble back the report has
already been written and uh along with
the other two that I had and there's a
little caveat in it saying exactly what
we want to state that we are love with
the initial
amount okay great thank
you 10 minute break we have a 10-minute
break and it's good idea everybody get
up and stretch your legs and if you have
to walk down the hallway do it now okay
so that one goes on a regular yes two
that exactly you're the one that's
righten all the and they're already
written now we got just get pop it is
and I got to be
um
e
e e
okay we're ready to go ahead just a a
word of advice for members in the
committee we've had a little discussion
up here about if you're coming forward
with an amendment
would you please remind them upstairs to
three hole punch
them so that we can you know put them in
these binders here uh if not it just
comes a swamp of paper up here and it's
it gets pretty congested so that will
help so what we have next we have
hearings coming up and the first one
which we're on the dock here is 769
769 get to it
six9 I don't have a copy of that do you
have a copy of
769 I'm GNA go get a copy of
it I'll get okay okay so I would like to
recognize represent Linda G uh who is
the Prime sponsor of 76 9 this is a bill
relative to the base annual cost per
pupil of providing the opportunity for
an adequate education and Statewide
education property tax
rate welcome
representative thank you for uh having
me here I am representative Lind gold of
bford New Hampshire and I am proposing
this bill for school funding because I
believe that it is the duty of the
legislature to deal with fiscal matters
in the state and not the Judiciary
Branch so that is where why this bill is
being promoted by me I shall present
some of the findings that bring about
the need for this bill part two article
83 of the New Hampshire Constitution
imposes the duty on the state to provide
a constitutionally adequate education to
every educable child in public schools
in New Hampshire and to guarantee
adequate funding and that's from
Claymont School District versus
Governor uh first the state has the
exclusive obligation to fund a
constitutionally adequate education the
state may not shift any of the
Constitutional
responsibilities to local communities
and that's from opinion of the
justices next in 2021 the New Hampshire
Supreme Court unanimously remanded to
the trial court to determine if quote
the the amount of Base adequacy Aid
fails to sufficiently fund an adequate
education as guaranteed by part two
article 83 of the State Constitution and
that's from Kuka Valley School District
versus State also after extensive
output-based
analysis Dr Bruce Baker an expert hired
by the legislature's commission to study
school funding concluded that the cost
of an adequate education in a district
of average size and grade level
distribution without adjustments for
students who qualified for
differentiated Aid is
$9,99
64 excluding Transportation convel
versus the state after extensive inputs
based analysis Dr Kimberly REO Saunders
determined that the base cost of an
adequate education must must be at least
9,929 also excluding Transportation
conille versus the state also the court
found that the cost figures used by Dr
Rizo Saunders were quote both credible
and highly conservative conville versus
the state next Dr Robert castelle an
expert Economist hired by the state of
New Hampshire conceded that the base C
of an adequate education in
Massachusetts exceeded $10,000 per pupil
gonell versus the
state next the Superior Court determined
that quote that the legislature should
have the final word but the base
adequacy cost can be no less than
$735
1 per pupil per year and the true cost
is likely much higher than that the
current allocation of
$4,100 per pupil is unconstitution
Condell versus the state in determining
the absolute minimum of
$735 1 the court noted that it used
highly conservative ratios that reflects
the minimum cost that would be incurred
by a hypothetical School District in
which no students qualify for
differentiated Aid conville versus the
state next the state is currently
funding base adequacy in charted schools
at a rate of $9,000 per
pupil and also in order to comply with
part two article 83 of the New Hampshire
Constitution base adequacy for district
students must be
increased so thank you for taking my
testimony and in my printed testimony
will be all the proper references to the
orders and findings also when once again
I want to tell you that I believe that
it is the duty of the legislature to
deal with fiscal matters okay thank you
thank you very much representative are
there questions for representative
gold yes representative luno thank you
very much um um representative G for for
bringing this forward and and also thank
you for um for noting the uh the
commission report and then the
involvement of Dr Baker and others um um
several of us on around this table we're
on that um that that commission but I
noticed in this you also got some u a
revenue component too pardon me you've
got a you've got a a a change to the
Statewide education property tax and I
was wondering if you could talk a little
bit about well would you mind if uh you
forwarded that question to uh to uh Miss
Ewing she's coming to speak after me
okay that' be better sure no wor thank
you okay thank you I I'd like to also
note for the committee we do have
Department Revenue Administration here
which has handed out a handout on that
showing some of the con the implications
to that uh they're here if you have
technical questions to ask of them I'm
sure they'd be pleased to try to help
you out with that okay I would like to
go to Donna magon okay
[Music]
still morning good morning and thank you
again for having me here today I really
appreciate it and I apologize for some
of you that um may have already heard
part of my speech but I think that I
have a little bit more to add and as
you'll see I'm very passionate about um
having more funding for our
students um good good morning my name is
Donna magon and I serve as a
superintendent of the Newport School
District education is the foundation
upon which opportunity is built
yet our ability to provide an adequate
education is under significant strain as
a leader of a district that serves 751
students I see the daily challenges we
Face due to Staffing short shortages and
the increase in the needs of our
students at present we are short 14
teachers and 27 of our 83 educators are
working under an alternative plan
meaning that they are not fully
certified in their assigned
roles this has a direct impact on the
qual a direct excuse me this has a
direct impact on the quality and
consistency of instruction on our
students Beyond Staffing concerns nearly
half of our population 327 students
require an individualized education
support of these
29% have an IEP
plan 15% are on a 504 plan plan and 16
students are English language Learners
and I would also like to add that just
this morning we had two more students
that are looking to enroll that are
English um second language
students this these students are
specialized instruction targeted
resource and trained professionals who
can meet their diverse learning needs
the increased complexity of our
classrooms only add to the demand placed
on our already stressed
Educators ensuring adequate education
requires more than good intention it
requires proper funding without
significant financial support we cannot
attract and retain quality te teachers
nor can we provide the critical services
our students
need the consequences of underfunding
are far-reaching affecting not only
graduation rates and career Readiness
but also the long-term economical health
of our
community I do not make this request
lightly but today I am asking or
pleading for your support
our students are not just statistics
they are the future of our town and they
deserve better investing in education
means investing in a strong Workforce a
more engaged public and a a thriving
community on Saturday our school
district's operating budget passed at
our deliberative session however our
financial concerns remain pressing after
the March vote we will need to identify
394,161
48,49 that is
only
264,000 they are necessary commitments
so these would be any obligations that
we had um contracts or so forth um so
that that's why our budget is only
changed the
$264,300
that is why I Ur am urging you to
support House Bill 769 which seeks to
increase the base cost of providing the
opportunity for an adequate education
and changes the Statewide education
property tax without this essential
funding our ability to meet these
obligations while providing a quality
education will be in Jeopardy this is a
this is a pivotal moment we cannot
afford to Short change our students I
ask you to take action and support House
Bill 769 for our children for our school
for our future and for our community
thank you thank you very much are there
uh questions for Miss mcum yes represent
luno thank you very much Mr chair thank
you very much superintendent for uh for
joining us again um in your in your in
your remarks just now you concluded
saying we can't afford to short short
change our children and and um and I
certainly felt that way you know um
during my you know 12 years on the
Hopton school board but you don't have
to go very far up the road to get to
Newport and um and with with very very
different student outcomes uh in Newport
and I think largely because of school
funding but I was wondering if you could
talk about some of those outcomes um
particularly in light of the the recent
um nape U uh scores that have been
released and I know they were just
released in the last handful of days so
right right so we haven't really had a
chance to to dive into it because we've
been moving forward budget right because
budget right now is is in the Forefront
um but what I can tell you is so if I
look at last year compared to this year
last year I had three fifth grade
classrooms this year I have two I have
25 to 26 child children in class
now um you know when I had taught back
you know back many many years ago when I
taught it wouldn't be unnatural for a
teacher to have you know about 20
students in the class but things have
changed right we now are we now have we
can't segregate our children right so
we're putting all children in class
together now so that's causing some
major issues in the classroom right so
we have children that are throwing desks
we you know chairs and we have children
that are throwing things we're having to
you know move children out of rooms
that's paying a huge toll on the
academic outcomes of all of our students
right not to mention the the stress that
the kids have to go through seeing this
type of of behavior we are hiring staff
that are are brand spanking new and some
haven't even gone through the education
track in schools right so they're coming
to us and it may be for instance we may
have someone that had a business degree
that decides oh I'd like to teach math
and so now they're coming into our our
building and we're we're training them
how to teach math but they've never had
the experience of student teaching so
they don't have that aspects of being in
the classroom so that's really paying a
role uh you know toll on our students um
I'm not saying that our staff is not
good by any means our staff is
incredible the things that they put up
with on a daily basis right they're now
um having to be a guidance counselor
right because we have so many kids with
trauma in our classrooms uh last last
week I want to say I had
um 4 68 probably about 10 to 12 dcyf
reports that were handed to me and we
had probably three I think three
students taken away from their families
so we have a lot that's going on in
Newport that you don't find in a lot of
other areas right which pay a to that
plays a toll in in the education of our
students and so I think it's all of that
put together right it's the behavior
it's the larger class sizes it's not
having the experience in the classroom
um we have a lot of students a lot of
students that their parents may have
went to Newport and they don't trust the
school system and so we're having to try
to work with them but when you're having
a new teacher every year the teachers
can't build this teachers can't build
that relationship with the parents so
all of this is paying playing a a huge
role in on the Newport School District
So currently we are trying in our budget
we are trying to get raises for our our
staff but it's not nearly enough is what
people are making just down the road for
us right and it's and some people say
it's much easier just to drive down the
road and not have to deal with some of
the behaviors that you're dealing with
in Newport right it really takes
somebody special to to work in Newport
and stay in Newport I hope I answered
your question thank you very much
represent spillsbury
welcome again miss mcon thank you um so
the bill changes the swept concept from
a fixed 363
million which effectively has uh a
Statewide rate of 1.12
and of course that varies then District
or town to town depending on equalized
valuation and the bill converts that
into a fixed rate
2.5 uh it's hard to know how exactly
that would play out in Newport but if
we're going to increase the amount
raised Statewide from 363 million to
8811 million more or
less how do you think that particular
approach would play uh with the uh
people who live in
Newport I think it would be helpful
right because what we look at is
anything that we could provide to help
with our community offset tax rates is
going to be very helpful for our
community we have a um large community
of um elder population that are
suffering because of the cost to them
most of the cost comes from our
taxpayers so I think if we could offset
it more and most of our cost comes from
the state or this from the school
district part then um we're not having
to go after our community so I think
that any little bit that comes in is
very helpful for our
community yeah followup followup please
yeah so I mean what swep will do is
apply to the property tax right the
state portion of the property tax so I I
would guess that the only way in which
that becomes a net benefit
to uh the taxpayers of Newport is if the
state then
reallocates that
um uh that money um through
adequacy but if if the base adequacy is
raised to the 7,000 Uh I that that
number down to the penny always throws
me
$735 And1
yeah uh
that doesn't really reallocate anything
because it goes to every student across
the state
equally which I think it should right I
think it needs that's why it' be fair
and Equitable right I think that every
student is entitled to um their fair
share and every district is entitled to
what what the needs are of their
Community I'll leave it there I guess
I'm also concerned in terms of uh how it
impacts the voters of uh and the
taxpayers of Newport
questions from the
committee not seeing thank you very much
thank you very
much next uh person is Elizabeth is it
Ying good morning welcome thank you
chairman lad and members of the
committee thank you representative G for
sponsoring this bill my name is is
Elizabeth Ying I am a resident of
hopkington New Hampshire and along with
Michael Tierney I represented the 18
school districts uh that brought the
suit in conval versus
State those 18 school districts are
representative or are I'm sorry are
collectively responsible for educating
more than a quarter of New Hampshire's
public school
students and as any of you who have met
a attorney Tierney no he would much
rather have sent himself than me today
uh and he does send his
regrets while we served as trial Council
for those 18 school districts I am here
on my own behalf and not on behalf of
any District taxpayer or student and I'm
here in support of HB
769 the bill is pretty straightforward
as you've noted it increases the amount
of Base adequacy to $
7,356 And1 per
student which is the absolute bare
minimum amount necessary to educate a
child in conformance with part two
article 83 of the New Hampshire
Constitution base adequacy which is the
amount set forth in subsection 2A of
1984a is the amount of money that it
takes to educate the least costly to
educate child in the
state this bill does not address
differentiated Aid categories like
special education or programs like
building
Aid in the real world there are
constraints on efficiency that mean that
the actual base cost of educating the
least costly to educate student is
probably closer to $10,000 per people
but in conal the Superior Court found
that in a hypothetically perfectly
efficient District the base cost could
be no less than
$735 And1 per
student I do have copies of that
decision if any of you haven't read it
yet and would like a
copy to your question earlier
representative luno HB 769 increases
Revenue by increasing swept from the
current
$112 per thousand to $2.50 per thousand
and at that rate $2.50 per thousand
swept would still be less of 40 less
than 40% of what it was in 1999
uh finally I just want to note with all
due respect that I believe there might
be an error in the fiscal note based on
fiscal year 26 data there are
151,939
37 for each of those students is an
increase of approximately 470 million I
was unable to confirm whether charter
school and EFA students were included in
the Statewide ADM of
151,953
m777
to30 to ensure that the state is
providing the adequate education that
our constitution guarantees I ask that
the committee recommend adoption of HB
769 and I'm happy to answer any
questions the best of liability thank
you very much other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much thank you
um Revenue Administration are you
willing to offer some technical support
to us in this
bill come on
up I you know you handed a sheet here
and I'd like to have you try to explain
some of the things within it but I'm
noticing in it that the the increase in
the swep will net
$811
approximately in Revenue which is kept
locally my question therefore is is this
the way we're going to really help uh
the property towns by Distributing
limited revenues or are we now putting
more money into towns which are going to
really build build up a huge savings
account from
this um chairman lad I'm not
sure how to address that question um I
know that if and as the that guide that
I we handed out mentioned this was just
take um the most recent uh swept
calculations and change that rate to
$22.50 per thousand and and that would
generate would have as it the note said
approximately $800 I think gu 11
million
um from our
perspective everything else is the same
at that point the $811 million would be
a portioned based on those equalized
values um so the math in this it's a
hypothetical but the math is pretty
straightforward so whatever a
municipality saw the warrant to raise
with the
$112 it would be if if we're just
generalizing it was wasn't 148%
higher those are the dollars then that
would be used to calculate the local
school rate so in representative
spilsbury's example if you're in
Newport you would be expected the town
would be expected to raise for the
school
district I don't have newport's number
in mind but at 148% increase it should
be two and a half times the dollars I
believe
so that's all I can really speak to as
to what that does and again as we read
the the bill is not attempting to change
anything else and I I'll leave adequacy
to my colleague at education to discuss
those and the implications and for
adequacy to to swept amounts but the
swept would
be we would do the same calculations
except we'd use
250 and then we'd a portion the 811
million and we would determine the local
school rate each fall based on on those
warrants and again we don't get involved
after that point I know that the a
municipality will raise that through the
property taxes and um I'm pretty certain
it combines it uh the swept dollars with
the local um School rate itself and
those funds move to the school district
thank you represent spilsbury and then
represent luno thank you Mr chair so
given that all of the swept collected
stays in the municipality under current
law there is no reallocation going on in
terms of how the money gets reshuffled
the only allocation you're talking about
is the
determination based on the equalized
valuation adjustment to the dollar 12
correct Statewide average
yeah can you tell us roughly what is the
dispersion around that mean in the rates
that actually are applied in the various
municipalities um from a low to a high I
cannot I've never conducted such an
analysis pretty dramatic isn't it like
maybe a factor of um
1.5 I repres I'm going to decline to
comment because I've never done that
analysis so I don't want to use words
like large or small I do not know I know
that they're not identical and I don't
want to put words in your mouth and I
don't recall specifically but off the
top of my head I think that individual
communities can end up with a swept rate
today as much as around 1.65 depending
on what the equalized valuation
adjustment does to the 112
average
so yeah it in other words for those who
might imagine that this bill results in
further redistribution amongst
municipalities um the bill as it's
written would not actually achieve
that yeah the only distribution you
mentioned is what we do every year which
is to take the amount of taxes which for
the last 20 years has been set at $363
million or the closest we can get it
over um and then a portioned to the
259 municipalities based on equalized
value
um thank you pran luno so thanks thanks
very much Mr chair and thank you very
much Mr canu for for joining us again um
and I I want to sort of drill drill down
on on what Representatives lad and
spillsbury were were just talking about
and um and just sort of you know take
this into a a you know real situation
we've been talking with with the
superintendent from Newport about um
about Newport and about the challenges
they have there and so um so uh there's
another um there's another town in New
Hampshire that also begins with new and
it's called new capap
and under the current um under current
law with swept at a buck 12 buck
12,000 um Newcastle Nets almost
$40,000 per um per student that's
correct and um and so by increasing so
so my understanding is would would
increasing swept from a buck 12 per
th000 to
250 um uh per per th000 more than
doubling it wouldn't that net Newcastle
over 85 maybe
$90,000 per per
student never done that calculation
either representative it's just not part
of our methodology so um I think my
colleague at education would answer that
one very quickly but the number of
dollars I'm going to generalize here
because I don't have the figures in
front of me but if the swept rate was
$2.50 per thousand this this last year
and we had done it and everybody's Val
equalized valuation is
identical I think you can just take that
increase and and use it for every single
community so I'm making this up I
because I don't know if newport's swept
warrant said raise half a million
dollars then the local swept rate in
Newport would have been set by us to do
just that at a112 for the the Statewide
if it was
250 um it's going to create 811 million
a portion right it's going to just
simply change the Newport swept rate
applied in Newport from whatever it
was to something higher right so so
quick followup so so so if you're a if
you're um uh if you're a city or town
with with low property values given the
the number of students that they have
but you know a town with with lower
property values um that will net you
less than a town with substantially
higher property values like like a
Newcastle so so um so it would it yes it
it would it would I think what I'm
hearing you saying is that yes it would
net Newport
more maybe double what they're what
they're netting right now per student
but for places with substantially higher
property values it will also net them
more too and and you know those doll
those differences in dollars you know it
might net Newport another million
dollars but it you know but it'll it
could not the the way the tax is is
currently
structured New Ports going to raise its
share of the 8811
million and again as it's structured
that share whatever that dollar amount
is is staying in Newport moving through
the town to the school
district and so
it in this
analysis nothing's changing except for
the amount of tax dollars being raised
in each of the 259
municipalities UND
swept they would all go
up and I suspect I think if I'm right
the math is they'd all go up by
148% the
dollars great thanks very much you're
welcome further questions from the
committee yes representa Damon thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question so is it correct then to
understand that this
proposal to increase the swept
rate does not in any way lower local
property taxes since the swept is
collected and kept in communities it's
just another version of the local
property tax it's a distinct tax it is
it's the state
tax
um holding all other variables
steady if you raise more tax dollar via
the swept tax rate in each
municipality then those are more
property taxes in and of
themselves thank you you're welcome any
further questions from the
committee thank you very much you're
welcome chairman L I forgot to identify
myself but I hope I was going to suggest
a pink card
but well I don't know if the clerk needs
anything that's what we'll we'll need
you might introduce yourself right now
because youve been for our committee
before but there's new folks here so
sure uh my name is Bruce canu I'm the
supervisor of the municipal Bureau which
functions under the municipal and
property division of the Department of
Revenue thank you Bruce you're welcome
and and if you could get the a pin card
back where Jen is right there and fill
that out we'll put that as part of the
record as where you gave technical
support and we also have a copy of your
report right here as well okay thank you
okay Mr chair was there a fiscal did we
get a fiscal note from LBA on
this Ju Just the notes from the Dr yeah
just the quick guide
okay no we've done
that
well we we didn't get a revised fiscal
note though from LBA no it just as
introduced
here um do you have is there something
else came through here though I haven't
seen it as introduced it was simply
saying that they were unable to complete
right and I haven't seen an update right
so this is another one that we want to
get um
[Music]
yeah that would be
great Rick said okay yeah I've got in
fact mine is revised January 28th here
okay reach the
rest okay so the next bill which we have
is supposed to be starting right now so
and I'm the presenter in that so I'm
going to remove myself from here and
uh chair
please e
I'll begin by uh recognizing
representative lad Prime sponsor to
introduce this
Bill thank you very much Mr chairman and
members of the education funding
committee I'm here today to introduce uh
HB
773 uh my name is Rick lad I come from
hail New
Hampshire and represent a number of
communities up in the Upper Valley area
um this bill has been
introduced uh similar to a bill that I
introduced back in
2013 with representative guile uh it's
in reaction to uh the special education
Aid and the pration amount that is
occurring as you all know we've T
discussed it several times here that we
initially appropriate in the budget for
the special education Aid once called
catastrophic Aid $34
million and when we come out now with
the actual costs and all that's occurred
doe said no it's closer to
51.6 whatever million dollar there's a
$17 million gap and in current
legislation as you look at this bill you
can see on the bottom of the page the
first page there on line
29 um it says the Department of
Education shall distribute to the school
district not less than 85% of the
district's entitlement for catastrophic
Aid costs in the first in the fisal year
and we know that the the district has to
cough up first approximately $70,000 for
before the state even gets engaged after
the three and a half times up to the 10
times and then uh and then it's a 2080
split and then and and ratio and and
then uh once you get above 10 times it's
on on the state totally so the district
has to account for initially about $96
million when we have something like this
has occurred where there's not money
there in the budget to support what the
actual costs are then this bill this
legislation in this chapter of law
allows the the uh amount to be that's
due to the communities that have spent
the money to prate that down to fit that
$34 million figure so they have to PR
rate that out and so they're going to
charge to all the districts a certain
percentage and this year it's been
67% 67% of what they are expecting to
see and this bill would say the pration
rate can go no lower than
85% that's a similar figure that
represented gu and I put in back in 2013
recognizing this does occur not every
year uh in fact in in the past several
years it's been
that it's been a higher percentage level
much much much higher but we're down now
in one of those dips again where back
then we were also in the 60% range and
it was pretty untenable uh when a school
district's looking for these dollars to
come in and it doesn't then you have to
start uh borrowing from Paul to pay
Peter other words looking at the rest of
the operating budget if there's any
money's there you're subtracting from
programs um you're also uh maybe having
to have a special meeting to appropriate
dollars at the local level or you have
have you're going to have to do
something a tax ant anticipation note or
something to try to come up with those
dollars which you need to pay these
expenses so this is just one part of of
the special education uh area that we
need to look at uh there's other areas
where this says three and a half times
we've been looking at two and a half
times we' been looking at three times
the amount of the average preo cost
I I'm suggesting that this is just one
component but it's a component that has
been dealt with in the past and it was
rejected back in
2013 and um here we are again with the
same the same bill coming forward thank
you very much and I'll be glad to take
any
questions just I'd like to begin with
two quick clarifying questions regarding
your intent so 85% is your intention um
as as a a minimum yeah
and so I've just note it looks like the
uh analysis in our caption has a
misprint uh at
80% yeah 85% is what we had back in 2013
I was you know at first I was thinking
maybe we ought to put it at 90% or
95% but uh I I know a lot of people are
looking at that but that's very close to
what the 17 up to the 51 and uh I think
it's more realistic if we try to find
that in between ground and that's why we
had this discussion as I said back in
2013 and that's where it was decided
back then it may be different
now and
second in uh in lines 6 through n where
the pration requirement is being deleted
then uh in lines 29 to 31 where the 85%
floor is being inserted what happens
when
uh when funds are short and it's above
85% isn't that VI pration yeah and and
this is a a a discussion I had with
legislative Services should we leave
that in should we take it out I'm
leaving up to the committee right now to
look at this issue whether that area
that's struck up on the top there should
remain
in well exactly what I was thinking so
perhaps the first one stays in and the
bottom one then limits it
that's exactly yeah okay representative
luno thank you very much Mr chair thank
you very much representative llad for uh
for for bringing this um this forward I
think we're going to have a lot to uh
consider when it comes to cat to special
education Aid and to school funding uh
with all the bills that that uh with
different with different moving parts
and different solutions offered on this
one here though um would the special
education Aid uh still be subject to uh
budget
appropriation there the intent of this
bill was to leave it to be appropriate
the same way we're doing it right now so
appropriated in the budget yeah uh drawn
down from that appropriation and then
should it fall below should it not meet
the 85% then subject to Joint fiscal
request something like that that's the
way it's been done okay thank
you further questions from the
committee okay thank you very much
representative lad you're welcome I'll
get a pink card
in thank you and U I'm going to call
Caitlyn
berer representing herself
hi good morning honorable chairperson
and members of the committee thank you
for taking the time to listen to My
Testimony my name is Caitlyn Bernier and
I live in marac I am an elected school
budget committee um member and I have
looked in much detail into our budget
into our special ed budget into our Aid
into our grants all the different things
that we can look into and I have listed
listen to our taxpayers in our town and
their concerns with the increase in our
budget and in their property taxes and
that it is more and more challenging
with the increased costs of special
education I've been deep diving into as
much as we possibly can into our budget
and these aren't things that we can uh
take on at a district level for our
taxpayers I'm only here to speak for
myself though today
and not on the budget committee and I am
in um opposition of this budget uh this
change and the increase that it would
cause our districts for special
education if you were to break down that
uh 50 million or whatever that amount
was to districts it would be about 9
million more that each district would
have to take
on we can even take on the increases
that we have now how are we going to
take on more because the state isn't
holding up their end of the
bargain we are educating everybody
because that's what public Ed is you
educate everybody and then we're
supposed to get reimbursed a certain
percentage and then if the child's
education is over a certain percent
we're supposed to get 100% coverage of
that and that's not happening and it's
really hard for taxpayers to understand
that and that this isn't something that
should be a problem with educating all
students and it's starting to become one
I'm hearing people talking about well do
we have to educate special ed do we have
to get all of our children education do
they all deserve it and I'm here to tell
you yes they all deserve to be educated
everybody does
so it is your responsibility to make
sure that the state holds up their end
of the bargain since we're doing our
part and we continue to have an increase
in our taxes even if our budget didn't
increase this year our taxpayers still
have an increase to their bu their
property taxes regardless of our budget
so now you want to add another 9 million
in the future onto the things that we
already can't take
that you're not being aware of what's
going on in your communities if you're
doing
that um I think that's all I have
somebody ask
question thank you yes representative
papich Muller thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for being here and testifying
and taking
questions you are referring to
reductions in the support from the state
the way I read the bill it seems to
increase the amount we would be sending
are we you know are we on agreement on
this do do you want you know for example
this year we would only be able to pay
about 2/3 of the amounts that are owed
under a previous version of the bill
this would make it mandatory that we pay
at least 85% so I'm just want to make
sure that you know we are talking based
on the same understanding of the bill
yeah the way I read it is that if you
don't uh have enough of that money in
your your budget that we just don't get
that amount back and we're just stuck
with the little bit and that's just you
get what you get and you don't get upset
but we're upset thank
you for the record representative
Lun thank thanks very much um uh for for
um for joining us this morning M Miss
berer um what I'm what I'm what I think
I'm hearing you say is that is that you
would like to see a bill like this
strengthened to guarantee the Grant and
not not just set a pration floor yes yes
I like a guarantee so that we know we
are educating everybody because that is
what you do in public Ed and that we are
receiving that reimbursement and that we
know we're going to get it we don't get
it till the next year but knowing that
it is a guarantee and the districts can
depend on that yes thank you thank you
representative Damon thank thank you Mr
chair thank you for being here um so
just to be clear we all would agree that
85% is more than this year
67% and is profoundly less than
100% could you speak to the impact of
districts not
knowing what amount under the current
Pro rating system they're going to get
and and how that plays
out yeah so um in uh in the budget it
would play out as you have to uh kind of
guesstimate how much you're going to
have to put into the budget for special
ed and take into consideration that you
might have some students that come into
your District that need out of District
that need some sort of extra so you have
to kind of give yourself that cushion
and the perception can be at times that
if you give yourself that cushion and
then end up at the end of the year with
a surplus it's as if you are holding on
to money for yourself when in reality
you are anticipating needing money and
then you know just like with any budget
I would hope that I if I can get under
my grocery budget then great job but you
know we don't want to go over it we need
to stay under it and you know they we
try to have under it but the perception
isn't always that we are um um funding
the education that the students need the
right way because people don't always
know what the cost is for special ed it
it varies and the fact that it varies
based off of what you get you pay
educationally from your school district
you don't pay like the medical and all
that stuff that's all kind of hard for
people to
understand yes representative thank you
very much and again one last quick
question
question would in your opinion this bill
is written be an improvement both in
terms of the amount of money that would
come into the district and in terms of
reducing that uncertainty you just spoke
about I understand that you may want it
written differently but as written right
to what you're formulating an opinion
would it make things better or worse by
itself um I think that it I would have
to read it again but um I think that it
would potentially be
in the uh short term but I I think that
um we need to increase just in do the um
amount that we're supposed to fulfill
thank you thank you so just to followup
on that I'm I'm interpreting your your
concerns and I want to see if I have
this right clearly this is an effort to
mitigate a problem that's manifested
this here at 67% with the
shortfall is it your concern that this
bill if it was passed with somehow
signal consent to make 85% a routine as
if yeah like it's an acceptable we're
just going to not meet what we were
saying we were going to and we're just
going to stop at that percent instead of
the so 100% is the ideal and your your
concern is whether expectations uh even
amongst the administrators shift yes
okay any further
questions repres
I question on the language if we're
calling it an
entitlement why are we saying we're only
going to give you 80% of what you're
entitled to can can the language does it
have to be written that way because an
entitlement seems to see that that's a
very good question for our work
sessions okay yes I
agree very good seeing no more questions
thank you very much Miss Baner thank
you okay I have no other pink cards is
there anybody who wishes to address the
committee okay seeing none I'm going to
uh close the hearing on HB 773 thank you
very much and Republicans we have a
caucus in State House 122
and and Dems we've got the beautiful
house Clerk's conference
room
e
e e
well good afternoon everybody we're
ready to go ahead and start our hearings
for the afternoon time the first one in
the docket uh scheduled few minutes ago
uh
HB 750 750 relative to making incentive
grants for school districts that improve
in certain no that's jumping down one uh
esta 747 establishing a program for
enrichment scholarships for gifted
students and making an appropriation
therefore and I'd like to I was about to
leave that's go back to your office huh
um so I'd like to welcome represent
cordelli to the education funding
committee uh thank you very much uh
chairman and committee members uh for
the record uh Glenn cordelli
representing tuon burough wolfboro and
Al in the beautiful Lakes Region um the
former education committee um heard uh
several bills um over the past few years
about uh gifted students um I think the
furthest we were able to uh move on that
was um with a collection of information
uh from school districts about programs
that they had
available um but I think I think we
heard that many schools if not most um
did not have uh programs in place for um
gifted and talented uh children and uh I
think that um we need to have something
available um for them um you know we uh
we talk a lot about um the students who
are not performing and assisting them um
but uh I think we also need to pay
attention to um those who um are uh
gifted and talented in one way or
another so that is the um purpose of
this uh bill for enrichment
scholarships and um on the first page uh
you will see um uh the uh definition of
quote unquote gifted students in Roman s
um and uh this uh came from uh a number
of sources um that I referenced um
including an associate an association
for gifted and talented students and um
several others um I believe there is
actually one State uh I think it's Ohio
that has a um uh gifted student uh
scholarship
program um but that's the only one that
I know of uh so um in that definition
you can see that U it's uh it covers uh
gifted students um for a number of areas
of giftedness which is defined but also
students that are categorized as uh
twice exceptional or maybe in the past
were twice gifted um uh
categorized um who have a disability but
also um a talent
uh so the idea is of this program is to
uh present an opportunity for families
of those children to apply for
scholarship uh the scholarship would be
run by the Department of
Education uh it would be an award of up
to
$1,000 uh annually uh for a student
and uh on page two I list um the uh
expenses for which uh the scholarship uh
could be used
um tuition tutoring uh instructional
materials um Etc on page two in Roman 3
um as you'll see on lines 10 on
down um and I even included on line 26
um therapies and so forth for those um
students who might be twice
exceptional uh there would be an
application process that goes on to page
three of the
bill um and uh the department would
actually establish a review panel uh to
review the uh applications for uh a
scholarship and um one person of the
panel uh would be some someone who is
trained in um the identification of
gifted
students um they would make a
determination on the ability
eligibility and uh the um the giftedness
and the amount of a scholarship um if so
determined u based on the uh application
and the uh expenses um and requirements
that the parents wanted to use the money
for U from the
scholarship um on the bottom of uh that
page um go into the responsibilities of
the
department um and uh I will note that uh
on the top of page four they can use an
electronic system um to uh track
expenses and so forth and uh I do know
that the department um has in the past
used the uh
same um system that is used by the
children's scholarship fund for track
and expenses in the EFA program the
department has used that system um for
um uh summer uh scholarships
programs um so that will help them keep
track of things um and monitor the
expenses uh um being uh requested by uh
the parents of the scholarship winners
uh the bill talks about
education uh scholarship service
providers um and their compliance with
law um one important thing is um the
rues um I specify what rules are to be
uh put in place by the department and
it's not uh um a wide open U Ru making
Authority for them uh but specific for
this um uh this committee um there is uh
appropriation
requests um one for the uh
scholarship um which I've requested an
appropriation of a million dollar a year
which would uh fund um possibly a
thousand students um each
year um but also a position within the
department um for an administ rator of
the program uh and um in the middle of
page uh six lines 12 through 14 I
outline um the uh um the
responsibilities of that administrator
position um and uh also an appropriation
of uh
$75,000 for contracted Services uh for
um uh needs that might arise uh for
instance on the review panel
um for contracted help um with that and
I I did work with the Department um in
putting this together um and
um um they were supportive of uh their
role um in this in this effort um and
with that I thank you very much and be
glad to answer any questions thank you
very much are there any questions from
the
committee Prof McGuire
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question um
in the fiscal note they don't put any
money for the new position in 27 or 28
is that a a flaw in the
bill
[Applause]
um um I'm trying to remember my
discussion with the Department if that
was um a position to get started or if
um uh or if it was my mistake in leaving
uh out the second year of the
budget um but um I I would think that
probably um a second year for that
position would be
required follow yes how much effort do
you think it will take for the committee
to process one application will they be
interviewing the student is that an hour
is that a how do you how do you envision
that don't necessarily en Envision them
uh interviewing um the student or the
family but uh really just reviewing the
panel and uh any school records that
were uh necessary to uh look at in terms
of uh their achievement
levels further questions
yes thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question um
can you just talk a little bit more
about the definition of giftedness
because I
as I read this on page one um lines 25
through
29 um you know general or specific
intellectual ability specific academic
aptitude creative or productive thinking
Etc and it says you know right above
that gifted students are capable of high
performance exceptional production or
exceptional learning Behavior now as the
mother of two children I can tell you
that I feel that they fit into that
category by my standards so I'm not
really sure what
the standards are then again on
page
three it talks a little bit um this
lines 12 through 17 or 18 it talks a
little bit about eligibility but it
still was very unclear to
me well um I I think that uh uh
giftedness um as as you point out is
sometimes in the eye of the beholder
especially when we're talking about
parents but
um I tried to leave it a little bit
General um it it's hard to Define
especially when you're talking about uh
different categories um it's not just uh
academ academic um achievement uh but
also it could be uh Arts um it could be
music um are uh areas where uh someone
could qualify um for a scholarship under
this program I believe um and um again
uh I I tried to uh research as much as I
could um about uh definitions and what
criteria might be used um and uh this is
um what I came up
with
B so what would the criteria
be there there's no um I'm not going to
if you look at for instance um I've
looked at um the gift twice excuse me
twice exceptional category and um I've
seen one definition that says um a
disability plus an IQ of 130 or above um
I didn't want to um get into anything
like that um I wanted to have more
flexibility because um uh I IQ
I don't think is a a total measure of
what we want to um uh provide students
with a scholarship for um it's as I said
uh on line six excuse me 19 um abilities
talent and po potential for
accomplishment further questions
representative luno thanks very much Mr
chair and thank you very much
representative um uh so the uh the ear
earlier it may have been late last week
the um the N tests uh test results came
out for all the schools in New Hampshire
yes and um both fourth grade and eighth
grade uh math and reading and I'm just
wondering in your opinion in your
opinion um do you believe that um that
there might be more gifted students or
in your opinion gifted students um um
from the um the the school performing at
the top of the nape test than at the
bottom um that's possible I I would hat
I would hate to put a definitive answer
to that um because you do say Statewide
assessment tests being being they right
but there there are children who do well
on the Statewide assessment um in in
every school district right I'm just
saying more more do you think there's
more at the top than at the bottom
that's possible
okay further questions from the
committee yes thank you Mr chairman
thank you for bringing this forth um is
there an assessment I have two questions
is there an assessment for giftedness
and the second thing is suppose that you
have a thousand uh recipients of the
scholarship the first year are they
grandfathered into the second year do
they need to reapply or is there more
going to be available to more gifted the
next year um
uh the first first part of your question
was uh a test is there an assessment
that would say that these are gifted and
these no no um and um I don't see this
as uh necessarily um a student
qualifying for every year in high school
or every year from seventh grade on um
this could be uh uh a targeted uh length
of time so there would be an annual
application
and that would also give more students
the ability to um to get an enrichment
scholarship I got one question you've
probably heard me say it many times
represent cour heli um uh the one of the
better programs we know is down at Yukon
uh in gifted and talented um the issue
we have here is that we have gone that
route many many times before and we
found the expense but we've also had it
countered by those that including the
previous commissioner not the one we
have right now said we have giftedness
we have giftedness in the form of AP
courses at the high school we have
giftedness in terms of some of the
selected programming which can occur at
schools and if we're going to truly get
into a gifted program we need to have
specific criteria conditions which I I
see some here but you know in in general
specific intellectual ability that's
usually done off a Wexler and you're
correct you know if you're talking about
standard deviation and all that usually
around 130 or higher may go down even
128 uh and then the academic aptitude
you know in terms of achievement testing
that's usually scoring 95% or higher on
two nationally normed achievement test
so in two categories within that test uh
creative thinking yes being creative and
Leadership skills within the school um
recommendations of the teacher
recommendations of the parent um so I'm
looking that number e to here where you
have on the first page Visual Arts
Performing Arts Musical and psycho motor
act
abilities are we now getting into the
area that of talented this where we
could have a program available for an
extremely talented golfer or a
basketball player uh
um that's that's where the question is
trying to break it apart between gifted
and talented right um yeah I I would not
see this uh extending into uh into
Athletics um but certainly um you know I
would want uh the Arts included in it um
including including music um if that
includes dance that's that's fine with
me um but um you know that's as far as
I'd be going on that score thank
you further questions from the committee
yes represent
E I see I see that you've got a
definition of scholarship service
provider here on the first page and then
uh sprinkled throughout our various
activities that are assigned functions
that are assigned to the scholarship
service provider or providers and
my question to you is whether those
activities the
awards um the papers produced by a
scholarship service program functioning
under this bill would be fully reachable
in an audit uh conducted by the state of
uh of the program in some's future
year the um
information um are you thinking that the
uh service providers themselves should
be audited is
that is that where you were going with
the
question could you P sry that's right
appreciate the advice um I often do that
um we all do I was thinking of the
program which in part in involves
scholarship service provider
and if and let's and I'm assuming that
an audit a performance audit would be
undertaken of the program including the
scholarship service providers and that
uh documents and information and uh
people uh would need to be accessed that
are under the umbrella of the
scholarship service provider and the
question is whether uh that information
would be fully accessible in that
audit um I'm not sure about fully
accessible a lot of that is uh private
information from the service provider
but the program uh should be uh uh
annually reviewed by the
department F
further Reon
Damon thank you Mr chair bear with me a
second I lost my place
um
sorry no I can't find
it I've
lost I apologize I can't find where it
was carry
on see you want us to come back to you
please represent Brown what are you
looking for
thank you um under tuition for
individual classes Public School Charter
Public Academy could the the tuition
also be used at a community college for
example I I think that that's uh
probably a good addition to that list
yes I I have a question until represent
Damon comes up with hers um under those
areas which the the program be possibly
used for on page two
you have done Educational Services and
therapies including but not limited to
occupational Behavior physical speech
physical speech language Audiology
therapies those are now some provided by
special education special
services um are you going above and
beyond what's the speech pathologist or
the physical therapist within the school
is currently
providing or responsible for in the IEP
um it uh I I think was left up to the
parent if they thought that they needed
additional uh therapies this would be
for for instance a a twice exceptional
student
um if the uh IP for instance called for
X number of hours but the parent wanted
to do uh more because of the uh uh needs
related to the talent of the student um
or the giftedness of the student um they
could um provide some um via the
scholarship okay repres Damon are you
there
yet yes thank you Mr chair thank you for
your patience there's a lot of pages
here uh in any case and thank you for
taking my question on page five line 16
and
17 um I'm concerned about that allowing
a quote unquote scholarship service
provider to limit access to Services by
a student and discriminate for a variety
of different reasons like to limit their
services to people of one particular
Creed for example is that the
intent
um the uh intent there is that um we
want to provide the independence of the
service provider um
uh religious freedom for instance is um
you know the main thing in in my mind um
I don't uh anticipate that uh anything
along those lines would come into play
with this kind of scholarship uh program
but um wanted to have that Independence
um in the
statute P up yes thank
you would you entertain an amendment
that indicates that scholarship service
Prov ERS cannot discriminate against
students um I I think that that is um a
little bit broad for my um perspective
but um it's the committee's bill
so further further questions represent
Ames on page uh what is this page
five lines 14 to 15 there's a statement
that any scholarship service provider
that accepts payment from the program
under this chapter is not an agent of
the state or federal government why is
that statement in
there um just to clarify that this is an
independent uh person um they are not
working on behalf of the state or the
federal government um this is um
language that's F found in many
um uh such programs and such uh uh
education scholarship um and education
um savings accounts
programs yes
representes but aren't the activities
and functions assigned to this provider
or these providers exactly what an agent
of the state would be doing that it
almost by necessity the description of
their functions and Duties are the
descriptions of what what is would be
done by an agent of the State uh but
they are they are working um for the
family at this point they are not
working for the state they're working
for the family and being paid by this
family via
scholarship thank you
Luna thank you very much Mr chair so um
is any of the determination of an
eligible student um connected with um
with the students Financial need no so
it's followup yes so so you're calling
it a scholarship but it's not it's not
connected with financial need so do you
think it's fair for taxpayers across the
state to fund these scholarships for you
know students that live in very affluent
you know come from affluent backgrounds
um I I think that uh we want to provide
for um the least of these as well as the
best and the brightest and um uh the
public education is to educate the
public and um we want to
um provide for these students um
regardless of their family background or
the area that they live um and we want
to help um those with exceptional needs
um provide for us in the future um to
have them succeed and if uh a
scholarship or a summer uh program will
help them do that then I think it's uh
in the state's best
interests thank
you
yes thank you Mr chair um so would
students
um from any particular
pathway be eligible for these
scholarships um is it only you mentioned
public school is it only public school
students who would be
eligible I I believe that's what I
indicated in the eligibility on the
first
page yeah right public
right any more
questions thank you very much
one more then we have
other
sorry I'm C here so on page
two uh Roman numero three the various
um items or services that could be
covered I don't read this as having any
um accountability so for instance line
2122 covering computer hard internet
connectivity
Etc there how do we verify that I
mean I as a parent can just have the
scholarship pay for Wi-Fi at my
house is that appropriate is that what's
intended let me rephrase that is that
what's intended um if uh someone in the
North country does not have um uh
internet access um
um but has a scholarship um then uh
internet connectivity would be an
allowable expense in my opinion but um
the department will write those rules um
and I know they have in other cases uh
said for instance you can only buy a new
computer every X number of years things
like that in
rules thank you further
questions not seeing thank you very much
have a good afternoon
uh represent
Moffett thank you Mr chair I hadn't
planned to say anything but I uh
obviously some of you know I'm
interested in this topic and I just
quickly wanted to point out that a we've
been down the short a little bit before
a couple terms ago we did pass HB 321
which simply required uh school
districts to submit a report to the
Department of Education on what if
anything they do for gifted students uh
as luck would have it uh I was uh doing
some legislative tourism this morning
going from room to room and I happened
to come in here and I sat next to
representative not representative
attorney Diana Fenton from doe I just
happen to uh float by her uh and remind
her that we did do this measure uh a
couple years ago about gifted students
and I I said some of us are interested
in what doe may have compiled uh since
we passed uh HB 321 so anyway I just
want to let you know that uh I I did
mention gifted to doe and Diana this
morning and the the other thing I just
would like to say is that when we did
321 couple terms ago that was not the
first time it came up we had brought it
up uh the term before it was sent to uh
interim
study uh and one of the things we found
out in interim study is that new New
Hampshire was arguably one of the worst
maybe the worst based on the research
that we got from interim study the maybe
we like say New Hampshire is number one
so often but in terms of gifted student
uh taking care of that population we
arguably were the worst in the country
in terms of identifying and and
supporting uh gifted and talented
students uh Mississippi uh we our
research showed Mississippi who we
always like dump on uh in terms of what
they do for Education was doing some
really neat stuff for gift so anyway I
just wanted to say that whatever the
committee does or doesn't do with with
this uh HB 747 I I just want to
emphasize that uh New Hampshire uh could
and should take a look at uh what we do
or don't do or could do for for the
gifted
population thank you Mr chair thank you
very much representative any
questions not seeing thank you very much
um Mary
wiy oh sorry I should know this by
now thank you for your help and thank
you for listening to me um I'm Mary
wilky I live in conquered um and um I'm
opposed to this bill I um I agree though
with representative cordelli that we
need to pay attention to gifted and
talented students I just don't see this
as the best way to do it um f first of
all I think that before we direct money
uh to private providers outside the
school system our first priority should
be ensuring that every student in every
Public School including every gifted
child in public school has access to an
excellent education that meets their
needs and uh that means fully funding
the opportunity for constitutionally
adequate education
in many cases children discover their
aptitudes while they're in school and
for instance I know a young man who
became a translator in his adult life um
the reason he came to pursue that path
is because he took language classes at
conquered High School um yet many public
school students in New Hampshire don't
have access to language classes because
there their schools can't afford to
offer them uh they won't know that they
have a gift their parents won't know
they have a gift they haven't been
exposed to it
uh similarly students who attend schools
that can't afford art or music um they
can't discover unless they're doing it
on their own unless their parents are
providing opportunities separately and
privately they won't know that they've
got this talent and so shouldn't we make
sure that every student in New Hampshire
has all the opportunities that we say
they should have um in arts instruction
language instruction Etc so that uh they
know that they can pursue their aptitude
udes and their interests before we spend
money on public money which is limited
of course on after school or outside of
school private opportunities um I'm a
retired teacher and I do acknowledge
that meeting the needs of gifted and
talented students is challenging and I'm
not talking about your straight A
students we have them every year we
prepare for them we know we need to
challenge them we work on challenging
them we differentiate our instructions
so that they're challenged but when you
have a really trly sort of out of the
norm child it's challenging and and I
would always take that responsibility
really seriously but I didn't feel that
I always succeeded I tried hard and what
would have really helped me because my
school district did not have a gifted
and talented program what would have
helped me would be if there was somebody
I could consult with and I'm thinking
that this person that under the current
bill would be at the doe reviewing
scholarships and helping that
scholarship program If instead it could
be somebody who's uh an expert in gifted
and talented and education collects
resources and a teacher could contact
and say I've got this student and she's
just like ready for college level
calculus and I'm teaching fifth grade
math can you provide me some resources
because it's beyond me I liked calculus
I took calculus but I can't figure out
how to teach a fifth grade student
calculus while I'm teaching 25 other
students how to do actions and and some
of them don't know their numbers yet so
I just feel like if IID had that would
be a better use of the money I agree
truly gifted students and I have some
concerns about how those would be
selected because we know squeaky Wheels
get degrees and it might be just the
most vocal parents not necessarily the
parents of children who truly are gifted
but truly gifted children deserve an
education that meets their very
different needs um and I think if if you
had
system that supported teachers in
meeting their needs that would help more
students they would help every school if
I got those resources in my school I
could then share them two years later
when somebody had the same issue and um
kids wouldn't fall through the cracks
and I do also I have worries about
accountability in this program um as I
read the bill it only requires providers
to tell the department that they want
that they want to be a provider
and that they won't rebate money back to
the parents and that they'll comply with
anti-discrimination laws but I don't see
any place where it's test where they
have to say that they have expertise in
dealing with gifted and talented kids I
mean I went through teaching training
school and I didn't feel like I had that
expertise and I worked hard on it I went
to trainings I still didn't feel like I
had the expertise I needed to handle
some of this or to meet the needs of
some of my students completely um so I'm
not sure who's going to who are these
people there may be people people who
are great at it but how do we know who's
I didn't see anything I may have missed
it but I didn't see anything in the bill
that said that the uh Department would
be reviewing these programs annually and
and I know that often in the EFA program
people say well the parents will be the
judge um I can say that if I were if I
had a child who was truly talented in
music and played the clarinet and I sent
them off with my scholarship money to
get clarinet lessons I wouldn't necess
bar know whether I could judge whether
the lessons were really good I don't
know enough about it and so I I worry
about accountability for that as well I
have other worries too but I'll stop
here thank you very much are there
questions from the committee represent
represent Luna thanks very much and and
thanks very much um Miss wilky for
joining us this afternoon um you talked
about a fifth grader taking calculus but
let me I mean I I I would i' have to
admit that's that's pretty speci but but
let's just let's just move move move the
dial up a little bit to like you know
more like an 11th grader or 12th grader
taking calculus and and and
um so so yeah there's yeah every most
high schools have kids that are in 11th
and 12th grade some 10th graders even
that are uh that are going to take um
take a Calculus class and and um uh they
might not be gifted in woodworking they
might not be gifted in art they might
not be gifted in biology but they they
like calculus my daughter came home one
afternoon as a senior in high school
comes through the door and said I love
calculous I mean said um said nobody
never yeah yeah yeah and uh and and she
now works uh works for the dean at seps
at UNH but not every school teaches
calculus classes and and I think we
heard earlier that that every school has
has gifted students uh or quote gifted
students in there maybe students that
might want to take a Calculus class and
would would you suggest that there are
better ways for the state to use its
million dollars to to maybe help some of
these schools that can't afford a
calculus teacher or can't afford to run
these classes or maybe um uh support um
students going to their Community
College to uh to to take these rather
than something that's really sort of
unaccredited and
un you know unever thinged so I would
and and partly because we know that
there will be some children who are in
that category and they don't they don't
get the scholarship either they don't
know about it their parents don't
realize that they need it their parents
don't apply somehow they fall through
the cracks whereas if the school has the
opport opportunity then the school will
offer it to that child but if it's up I
mean certainly parents want the best for
their children but they don't always
aren't always aware of these things like
a scholarship out there or they might
not be aware that their child is that
talented in a certain subject so I feel
like this would be a more broad-based it
would get more children more students
thank you are there any further
questions from the committee represent
McGuire thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question this bill
anticipates um giving a th000
scholarships which would be roughly one
for every 150 kids or something like
that is that seem to you to be in your
experience the kind of right ratio in
terms of a truly exceptionally
intelligent student comes along sort of
you know I I don't know if you had a
class of 20 students you see one every
seven years or something like that is
that right or is it more of a
Continuum where
there's not a a sort of a noticeable
jump between one to the next sort yeah I
kind of see that as two different things
and let me address the last thing you
said that's another issue I have is it
is a Continuum it's not like kids are
get to hear and then everybody stays
there and then all of a sudden there's
somebody way up there there's somebody
here there's somebody here there's
somebody here and so there's going to be
a cut off somehow
and why would one child who's really a
wonderful s singer and loves singing get
the state to pay for his singing or his
singing lessons and then their friend
who is I don't know somehow rates just
slightly more and gets in I don't know I
don't know what the ratio is that was
one of the things I wondered it doesn't
seem like I I know that the LBA didn't
get any information back from the um
Department the information they
requested to do the fiscal note I would
think there'd be a um statistics it
would depend on how you defined gifted
of course if there's a standard
definition and I really don't know if
there is if there is then there must be
statistics on that but in my own
experience I mean every year I would
have well I always felt like every child
was gifted uh and every child does have
gifts but I me it would be I also taught
Middle School where I had 75 children
every year and then I taught Elementary
was more like 25
um it would be every few years I would
see a child who was so beyond the the
normal range that all the usual things I
would do to really try to make sure
people were challenged didn't seem like
enough and I had to really find more it
wasn't every year for me thank you
that's good further questions from the
committee not see thank you very much
thank you and I don't have any other
pink cards in this bill so we're going
to close the hearing for HB 747
thank you very
much and have a good
afternoon uh the next bill which we
have is
hb750 uh relative to making incentive
grants for school districts that improve
in certain assessment
scores representative M welcome
thanks again Mr
chair for the record I am State Rep Mike
Moffett representing maram for the
beautiful towns of Canterbury Lowden so
the latest report card on America's
public education system just came out
last week as it has as we have it uh
January 29th and the numbers were
disastrous the national assessment of
educational progress that's the na the
test scores were were below
uh preco levels uh even as taxpayer
spending as you know so well uh on
schools has soared na tests carry a
maximum 500 Point score New Hampshire's
eighth
graders New Hampshire 8th grade math
scores were
280 uh according to the 2024 test
results which is significantly below the
the score of 295 from from 10 years ago
so anyway so there's some metrics
there's some numbers so what can or
should we do about this situation
terrible situation and this terrible
Trend in terms of academic
performance uh I've spent a couple terms
in education committee we spent a lot of
time on all kinds of things uh CRT Dei
bathroom policy cyber bully bullying
cell phones and on and on but as a long
time teacher Professor
educator uh I wish we'd spend a little
more time on learning on pedagogy on on
knowledge so what caner should we do to
promote learning uh this brings us to
hb750 and incentive grants again uh
there's a perception that schools don't
sufficiently celebrate or promote
achievement rightly or wrongly that
perception is
there uh why well some schools have
eliminated valedictorians for example
some have done Away With Honors tracks U
that perception that schools teach to
the lowest common denominator is out
there uh for the sake of equity or
self-esteem or what have you we've heard
stories including in education committee
um I remember parents coming in in
tears because their kids were not
challenged in school uh In This Very
Room I will never forget it so anyway
representative Hopson and I met with
some folks including the commissioner at
the Department of Education about the
the incentive Grant concept uh this was
uh 2 3 years ago so we talked about
formulas and and which assessments to
use and how to implement etc
etc but we realized that statute is not
necessarily the place to put in any
lengthy prescriptive equation as to how
to implement the incentive
concept we saw the greater challenge
simply as to how to celebrate
Improvement and achievement how to
reward
achievement and of course how to find
funding that's why we're here funding
and then how to task doe with working
out the
details in cooperation with relevant
stakeholders so once a formula is
established for an incentive program and
published then the schools would not
really compete against each other they
compete against themselves their own
Baseline um and of course there'll be
some statistical issues if a school is
already performing well I'm anticipating
that question uh if the schools already
performing relatively well then they
have less room for improvement than a
school that's not doing well and which
is kind of the point the schools that
are not doing well who do have room for
improvement they're the ones who uh need
to be recognized when they do improve so
putting this together we shouldn't let
the perfect be the enemy of the good so
as some of you know for a long time we
sent money lots of money many millions
of dollars of of funds to uh schools
that had low third grade reading scores
and some including including the likes
of me saw this as a perverse incentive
schools do lousy and they get
money and some folks thought that this
perverse incentive uh especially when
there's no accountability your third
grade test scores are terrible will give
you
and we'll just assume that you'll use
that money to improve your third grade
test scores terrible uh terrible concept
uh which has finally been identified so
back again to hb750 a version of this
came to House Education last term
actually last couple terms two terms ago
this concept came to House Education and
we had an interim study
committee of which I was on so the
interim study committee spent a lot of
time on this and came back to the full
committee and most all of you know
interim studies work so having put a lot
of time into the interim study process
we came back to the full committee uh in
October if you know how the schedule
works and the full education committee
uh indorse the OTP that the interim
study committee uh recommended so you
have interim study OTP House Education
in October OTP so we brought this back
uh this next term which was last term uh
some of you were here and I I was not in
the committee at this time but it was
amended and then tabled it was a deal
with tabling whatever didn't move
forward so here we are again U Back
Again so if and by the way uh it as part
of the interim study
process we initially the focus was on
all of academic and we and the the chair
uh actually the CH taking the chair's
input we focused on
mathematics so that's part of the
process was listening to people like the
chair narrowing the focus in this case
uh to mathematics so if incentivizing
achievement and Improvement in a school
winning a $50,000 award what what does
that mean uh number one it means a nice
chunk of money for the district to spend
as it wishes number two it means that
the school winning the award will have
reason to celebrate the whole school
Community will have reason to celebrate
you talk about self-esteem this is
self-esteem and morale and pride
improving at schools that that do better
and are recognized and rewarded for
doing better number three parents would
be thrilled I guarantee that who what
parent wouldn't be thrilled to know that
their school with their kids their
youngsters go uh is working at
Improvement and is and achieved
Improvement via the metrics of test
scores and and and was rewarded and
finally number four lessons could be
learned and shared win win win win now
folks might say or ask about a school
that won an award what did you do what
what what happened what did you do do
differently to improve your scores and
and to get this recognition in this
award um so again there some you know
I've been I've taught on every level um
I care about all stuff a school I once
taught at um in
Manchester had a math
team so and they had went to math meets
math competitions and so that's the type
of thing that schools maybe could look
at uh to improve math scores now uh
maybe they could create a math club I'm
just throwing stuff out maybe they could
involve Al alumni parents uh accountants
MIT grads maybe uh maybe they adopt new
texts textbooks or or pedagogy maybe
pull in some Engineers or technicians
who could speak to the relevance of
math on and on so all kinds of
possibilities and whatever truly
effective approaches that the
award-winning schools came up with could
be shared Statewide best practices so
school any Town High School try some new
things improve their improves their
scores well what did you do share that
and so it would be more than just the
schools that are recognized you know
Lessons Learned things that work share
that
elsewhere uh so an earlier version of
this bill recommended taking a million
dollars from the rainy day fund which
was flush uh I know you are all in
funding um new money for new new money
for Education from the rainy day fund
now was pointed out that the rainy day
fund was for emergencies to which I
think I said here a place like this I
said we keep in there's a funding crisis
an emergency for education so uh take a
a pit a relative pittance from the rainy
day fund um so anyway this time around
we're looking to redirect funds from the
massive education trust fund uh which
has uh as you know better than me
considerable dollars in
it so I already mentioned this mod has
come up a couple times before interim
study OTP um and so I I just want to
before we finish just point out that for
the anybody who's on an interim study
commission I've been on several you most
of you have probably been on several you
put all this time in you come up with a
recommendation the full committee adopts
your recommendation and then uh what
happens and if nothing happens then
that's uh that doesn't speak well of the
interim study
process so um the last thing I'll say is
uh in terms of the specific details we
get a little bit wrapped around the axle
before talking about this which test how
to do it what's the formula uh poor
schools different schools uh how do you
so the interim study team looking at
trying to put this together finally we
we
recognized that as I said earlier
statute is not necessarily the place to
have paragraphs and paragraphs of a
prescriptive formula for implementing an
incentive Pro
program it's uh so we are adopting what
we call the mission oriented
approach uh I can best describe that is
in the Marines you assign someone a
mission to take the hill so you give
them a mission you give them resources
and then you let them work out the
details without you know micromanaging
that the a lot of times the
micromanagement from above doesn't work
so uh we would uh trust the stakeholders
and whoever worked with doe to work on
the details what we need to do simply is
to endorse the concept the mission which
is to improve
learning and and provide some funding
and then the the details as I just said
the St stakeholders and thee would work
out so thank you for your time I hope
you'll U give this another good look and
I'd be happy to take any questions if
there are any thank you very much
representative are there questions for
representative Moffet yes representative
papovich thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative for putting the bill
together and
testifying my mother my late mother was
a lifelong teacher I taught for living
for 10 years I heard a lot of the things
that you were suggesting this bill could
uh motivate I have really a simple two-p
parted question hey isn't that the job
of the schools to do all that in the
first place and second if they're not
doing it already
would 50,000 be enough of a financial
incentive to suddenly motivate them to
do all this cuz my school budget is 60
mil and I don't think if they would
notice 50 th is anything other than a
rounding error to be honest so I would
appreciate your thoughts on this sure
representative thank you for the
question in a perfect world we would not
need policemen we would not need
supervisors we wouldn't need incentives
in a perfect world people would study
and learn for the intrinsic reward of
learning and many do do that but this is
not a perfect world and for a lot of
reasons uh sociological economic I'm not
getting into all that lot the test
scores that just came out last week
document a terrible failing Nationwide
and IND Hampshire and learning math so
to your point I get it and I wish things
were I wish every parent was engaged I
wish every school uh maximized it its
resources and did did a a better job at
teaching whatever you te in this case
math um so the the first part of your
question given this is not a perfect
world uh I think there is a place for
incentives and carrots and sticks uh
truthfully this is a carrot big giant
carrot there's no stick here uh so
hopefully that addresses your the first
part of your question somewhat second
part you know how much would $50,000 do
uh well it's not what it used to be but
I think any school uh in the towns I've
lived in if they got a
$50,000 reward uh they could do some
good things with that uh again the it's
up to the Local District but beyond the
the dollars that would help to whatever
degree the the schools the morale Factor
as I touched on earlier if a the
Community Pride and support for public
education would in that Community would
ably go up and I think that's what we
need and that's what we want this that's
what this could do so 50 Grand or
whatever the number is uh not a gigantic
number but it could do some good and the
value a lot of it is uh intrinsic not
measurable further
questions not seeing thank you very much
thank you Mr sh are there any other pink
cards on this bill not seeing we're
going to close the hearing on
750 pardon me
[Music]
you
s
e
e e
and we're ready to address the last bill
schedule for this afternoon HB
772 establishing a foundation
opportunity budget program for funding
public education I got a pink card here
from represent luno committee Ed fun it
is fun
so welcome thank you very much Mr chair
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is Dave luno representing
people who live in Mari County District
9 uh which are the folks in in the towns
of bow and hopkington and uh as I always
say all across the granite state as well
I don't give up conquered but I'll take
everybody else too and the reason is
because we've got statewide
responsibilities and one of our biggest
statewide responsibilities in fact I
dare say the biggest Statewide
responsibility we have in New Hampshire
is funding our Public
Schools there's no mistake in fact the
the the folks on finance can correct me
but I think I'm close I think the uh the
state's appropriation to Public Schools
is probably the largest discretionary if
I can use that term right spend that we
have and uh there's no there's no
questioning why um why there's an entire
Division division two of Finance
dedicated to um uh to school related um
related funding and um and you know it's
something that I think is as we go
around and and knock on doors during
campaign Seasons whether it's for us or
for other people whether in our district
or in other towns um people ask I think
we've all heard it what are you doing
about my property taxes and a lot of
people connect that and with a follow-up
question what are you doing about um
school funding um
I had the opportunity uh during this
past campaign cycle to knock doors in
Newport and and I I i' I'd like to say
it was eye openening but it wasn't
because I know a lot about um what's
going on in Newport with with how
they're funding schools and what their
challenges are and what their um um
school and student characteristics are
like and um and you know and I can see
from our current
funding formula that uh we've talked
about in the past it's one siiz fits all
you get the same base adequacy and
differentiated you know Aid package
whether you're uh whether you're a
student um uh whether you're going to a
school in Newport per student or whether
you're going to school in uh in wolfboro
or Newcastle and um and and and and our
current funding formula has been
described as um as having two sides to
it a leftand side and a right hand side
and I think of I've got him right the
leftand side is adequacy it's must pay
it's what it's what comes out of our
formula it's what comes out of our
constitutional obligations the right
side has almost as much money in it it
seems and is used to prop up the
adequacy formula with the extraordinary
needs Grant and supplementals Grant
supplemental grants and we're talking
about doing it again this year too and I
think we you know it it certainly is
very helpful and it's very helpful to a
lot of schools including Manchester and
including
Newport um but what I'm here to talk
about today is a new way of looking at
things and representative spillsbury put
it on the table um yesterday I think
yeah maybe it was Friday last week and
said hey can we look at maybe look at
things a different way and see what
might work for um for the granite state
so House Bill 77 uh
772 does that and um and and it does it
in um in three ways and now I'm
referring to the the explainer that I uh
that I put at everybody's seat so uh so
for a for afternoon Bill introduction um
it'll help us get get through this um
but uh it does three things it does
School funding
reform not just tweaking the same you
know um package that that we've the
school funding formula we've got in
place now school funding reform it does
it reforms the Statewide education
property tax and it also implements a
low and moderate property tax relief
program I'm not so much going to talk
about these last two things I'll talk a
little bit about them but um but uh we
heard we heard from representative names
last week when he introduced um House
Bill 734 that that this bill
incorporates um uh in its entirety for
those last two items but let's talk
about the um the the school funding
reform part what what came out
of
Claremont The Claremont decisions is um
is what's What's called the the the four
I guess four mandates that came out of
Claremont and the first mandate is
Define inadequate education this is the
job for the legislature all four of
these things it's the job for the
legislature legislature must Define an
adequate anuc Define an adequate
education the second thing is the
legislature has to cost it what's it
going to cost to put on that
program
for 161,000 students across the state
through a bunch of school districts and
saus what's it going to
cost the third thing is guarantee
funding for school districts to run that
program none of them are going to run
out of you know lack the resources or
lack access to the resources they need
to fund their schools that's the third
thing and the fourth thing is an
accountability package
how do we know that the schools are
doing the job how do we know how well
the kids are doing um how do we report
back to the
taxpayers
that that our students are about our
student
performance and we heard a little bit
about that earlier today too through
through the um Nationwide National
assessment Nate uh and we'll talk about
that in a little bit but it's these four
things that uh that that came out of the
clar decisions and direct us in the
legislature on what to do what are
responsible what our constitutional
responsibilities are to funding school
so what does 772 do that's different
than than uh than our one siiz fits-all
thing that we do do today well first of
all it
um it defines the opportunity for an
adequate
education um as being two things the
first thing the content areas that are
already described in rsa1 193
e2a and um we've talked a lot about
those in the past and we've even added
to them in the last um last couple of
years
um so it's got the substantive content
areas uh but it
also defines it for every District to
have to be able to educate their
students
to a Statewide
outcome so it's got a student outcome
component uh to this and that's really
important especially important in New
Hampshire because overall Statewide and
we're hear about this I hope there's a
card that's going to come in um and and
and because overall Statewide our our
students perform among the best in the
country I'm I'm here in top five I heard
top four from representative bricky uh
during lunch today um uh Governor sonunu
said top five a year ago so but it's
right around in there and I think the uh
the the scores we're going to hear about
also U support that uh position so so
Statewide outcomes are a strong outcome
from New Hampshire but it's just not
happening everywhere and and we heard
from um from the superintendent Newport
this morning that it's not happening
there
it's happening in a lot of other places
but it's not happening in Newport it's
not happening in
Manchester and when it doesn't happen in
when it does happen in Newport it's
definitely a problem I mean it's a
problem when it's not happening in
Manchester it's definitely a problem
it's a big problem because there's
13,000 kids there's thousand kids that
graduate every year from Manchester and
uh when the average student in
Manchester is is not performing at a at
a Statewide proficiency level then uh
then that's a real issue so um so we
Define it as content areas and in terms
of student student outcomes the second
thing all right now we got to cost this
thing what's it what's it going to cost
so so and and this actually comes out of
the I hold it up all the time the
commission report how to go about
costing um uh an adequate education
based on based on student outcomes and
so it calculates what's called a
foundation opportunity budget which
isn't you know the base cost of adequacy
with a bunch of little differentiated uh
things it's the budget that a school
district would
need so that all to well let me say
another it's the budget a school
district needs to educate all of its
students to a Statewide
outcome and
um when looking at that that that
Statewide outcome now you can look at
the average student in this district and
the average student in Manchester I mean
this is the budget budget for Manchester
so the average student in Manchester
would be performing very close to the
same level as the average student in
Hopkinson or the average student in
Handover um so that's the second thing
it does differently then our one size
fits all the third thing um it does is
fund it and how do we go about um how do
we go about funding this well in a sense
what what what we're doing in our in our
current model is we start with State
dollars the 4100 base plus the little
you know sparse little bits of
differentiate Aid and everybody gets
that and then the locals uh put in the
rest of the money to get them to uh to
get them to the school budget um 772
turns out on its head it starts with a
modest uh local share and I think 77
772 talks about
$538 do I have that right um per
thousand and um and and only if you need
only if you know $538 per thousand um
doesn't get if it if that's more than
you need to get to your foundation
opportunity budget then you can stop you
don't need to put in all $538 per
thousand but um but it starts with that
and and if if in your town that gets you
to your your foundation opportunity
budget or your share of the foundation
opportunity budget um then then you're
done then that's great
$538 that's all you need uh ,000 that's
all you need for um for prop or less
than that that's all you need for
property taxes but if that doesn't get
you there and in most districts it's not
going to get you there that's where the
state comes in with the adequacy Grant
and gets you the rest of the
way so local dollars First State dollars
get you the rest of the way rather than
rather than uh rather than backwards um
and um and that's probably the biggest
thing F Well if I were to say two really
big things about Foundation opportunity
plan it's centered on Focus focused on
student outcomes and paid for in a way
that lives up to our constitutional
requirement where the state guarantees
the resources you
need not the locals guaranteeing the
resources you need State guarantees the
resources you need and it also has a um
uh an accountability and and um data
collection system uh also in the bill
the Bill's 26 or so pages
long what are we at well it's 24 on this
it um uh so there's a lot to it and and
you know I think hope you know when we
when we hold the um uh the work sessions
that we'll really be able to sort of
crank into this we do not have a fiscal
note of the chair and I have have been
speaking with the department and the LBA
about where they're at and uh I think
they're more than a week away from
having a having a fiscal note obviously
the sooner the better um we've put uh
we've put similar bills in in the past
so I generally have have have um have a
sense as to what the fiscal note would
be and you know the first the the the
the two bills that I've introduced over
the last week uh talking about you know
an increase to the base using the conval
number and then an increase to the base
plus the differentiated U grants based
on conval and and ran I think
respectively added 500 million close to
500 454 million and then 630 million to
current law um earlier versions of this
bill that had little bit of a different
taper little bit of a different um um
base than what we're we're in right now
um added 200 was 20 million over current
law so as the state state starts to
spend break out of this one siiz
fits-all and starts to spend its money
distribute its money in a smarter way um
that overall price comes down because
we're not talking 90 grand going to um
to
Newcastle right so um so anyway the the
the price tag comes down a lot uh I'm
I'm very interested to uh to see uh What
uh the fiscal note does come come out
with and and Mr chair I hope also we'll
we'll be able to work with with Mr
landrian on on a fiscal note that may
have a town by town in there too because
I think that's a that's a really
important component to this like I said
earlier versions saw substantial
movement in uh in towns that had have
historically been left out and um and so
I think it's something we all need to
see it's also worth talking about
because I'm not going to talk about the
swept reform I'm not going to talk about
low and moderate income um because we
talked about that uh last week with
representative Ames um but what's also
interesting is what's not in House Bill
772 there's no
stabilization there's no hold
harmless there's nothing that props up
the formula the formula
works now to be fair it does and and
this isn't n necessary necessary for the
formula to work it does have a provision
for tax transition
grants so as as the As and and it has
a it's either an eight or a 10-year
phase in Period so this isn't a drop it
all at once you know type of thing we we
realize that that you know this is
something that that that's got to be
tapered in that has to be phased in um I
I you know I suppose if we were to ask a
superintendent what would happen if we
dropped a pile of cash you know on your
lap would you be able to spend it all in
year one you know a lot of them say yeah
maybe we could but but I think we all
know practically from business about you
know how you how you work with with
funding and tranches of money and um and
so I think this this has a smart
delivery and phase in of that similarly
and make sure that nobody gets hurt so
um um so and it does it all without
stabilization without a prop to hold up
um to prop up the formula uh so in the
long run the formula operates by itself
without an extraordinary needs Grant or
fiscal capacity disparity Grant or any
of these other stabilization props we've
used um in the past um so uh just for
just for a minute I want to make sure
that that everybody got a copy we did
get a uh what's called a a a fiscal note
quick guide from the from the the
Department of Revenue which I think is
terrific uh I talked with Mr canu about
it briefly because there's some comments
on here that say and and you know and
they got a lot of bills obviously to go
through but some comments that sometimes
in some cases throughout the bill we use
the word you know City town or
municipality other places we use the
word District those are two very
distinct things we were not
indiscriminate about how we um use those
terms in the bill when um when when
looking at um at at a
municipality's uh um obligation or
building out its share of the foundation
opportunity budget we're using the admr
per town so per
municipality um when calculating uh some
of the costs including the uh the school
district size we would use the word
District um in there so so U uh I'm not
saying that in a 24-page bill that there
aren't going to be some some drafting
errors on the part of myself and and and
there may be some that that that I'm not
saying it's perfect but I'm saying that
that that with with with full intention
to to understand and recognize and
utilize the difference between those
terms uh in there um the uh the last
thing I wanted to talk about in fact if
there's another card coming in then I'm
going to leave most of it um to the next
speaker but um but but when we when we
take a look at the um at the ranking of
nape um test scores um reading in math
for fourth graders and eighth graders
that came out last week and if you rank
them by um by by score from the highest
to the lowest um you'll see a pattern
that that I think the chair has um has
noticed before as well and um and I
think we could probably all without too
much trouble um guess the names of the
school districts that are on the top of
that list and the ones that are on the
bottom of that list and um and they all
uh have bearing on how the state goes
about
um funding our
schools and and you know none of us I
think want to be you know on the bottom
of of the nape score list whether you're
a taxpayer in Newport who's paying some
of the highest or Charlestown paying
some of the highest property taxes in
the state I'm not sure who's higher
right now Newport or Charlestown
Charlestown is yeah so um so you know if
you're taxpayer you don't want to be on
the bottom of that list if you're a
student if you're a parent you don't
want to be on the bottom of the list and
certainly if you're a student you don't
want to be on the bottom of that
list so
um with that I'll um sort of wrap up and
and I think we can do a lot to adopt a a
uh funding model that is based on
Research based on evidence based on data
based on on how many hours did we meet
at least 250 hours Mr chair back in 2020
on the school funding uh commission work
based on testimony uh that we received
um all over the country uh we had most
of our meetings with zoom which meant we
bring people in um uh uh National
experts in um uh in a lot of different
areas whether it was uh education policy
school funding policy tax policy and um
and
um anyway uh we're able to we're able to
offer something that breaks us out of
the one siiz fits-all and something uh
you know a lot more um Dynamic that that
recognizes the uh the different
challenges in different um um in
different cities and towns that we have
across the state so with that I'll take
um I'll take some questions but but but
you know save your save the best ones
for the work session please represent
papovich thank you Mr chair and thank
you for a detailed introduction to a
very detailed bill um I have a quick
question um in your early discussion of
the formula you said that the left side
of the formula is the adequacy and the
right side is I believe you said a
supplement to it or something along
those lines can you help me understand
which in your opinion are the components
of the right side of the education
formula that are not needed for adequacy
for an adequate education yeah so so
thanks for the question my understanding
is that is that
um
1984a is that the
the formula you're talking about
statutory yes statutory reference
1984a is the is the costing of an
adequate education anything outside of
1984a is not considered to be the uh
constitutionally um costing of an
adequate education quick clarification
if I may and is there any part of the
funds that we allocate on the right side
of the formula that does not go
specifically towards addressing those
1984 the obligations I I so I I believe
the extraordinary needs Grant is outside
of that I think that's considered right
right side of the
formula I believe yes um there may I
think there was there another grant that
that was added in the last
um well we've talked about like re
relief Grant yeah we talked about fiscal
capacity yeah um those are all right
side and then of course you got the hold
harm on that side of the formula yeah
and
um see the other one was
uh so other grants yeah they're they're
they're made I'm just not yeah but but I
think the biggies are the ones that you
just listed off Mr chair the the um the
extraordinary needs Grant and the home
hold harmless and uh and I don't believe
either one of those stems from uh RSA
1984a thank you and may I have a very
short second question thank you Mr chair
the other thing I was looking at your U
explainer uh it says that we should
calculate the foundation opportunity
budget based on the actual
costs right now I come from a school
district that Prides on providing an
education level that's Way Beyond the
adequate right I I'm from wiam how would
we go about in if we look at the Windham
educational expenses how much of that is
spent for the adequate education that
the state requires and how much you
spent for the choices of my local
taxpayers to go above and beyond
adequate sure no that's a great question
and that's where the student outcome
Factor comes uh comes in so we would
take a look at what the what the student
outcomes are in in Windom and um and and
take a look at what costs in what
category um when it it you know in what
costs in what categories because schools
do a bunch of different different things
and what types of students they're um
they're educating so so how many
students are um are from low income
backgrounds how many have special educa
been identified special education how
many English language Learners what size
your your school is um and um and when
looking at that looking at that dat
these data those data
from every school district uh around the
state you can start to see how well geez
so we we can see in Newport that that
their student outcomes are are here and
that they've got a very high I think
Newport has a fairly high percentage of
um of of students who' have been
identified as special education and and
so you can take a look at the spending
look at how they've you know through
through the um the um uh doe 25 the end
of the year doe2 is end of the year
actual yes end of the year actual and um
and and through an analysis be able to
determine what spending Works in what
areas and um and then and then determine
a budget based on um u based on based on
these data to get to get a Statewide um
student outcome thank you further
questions
yes Bron
Ames
uh
so I know because I've been involved in
this but I I wonder if you could speak a
little more
about how this this bill this approach
to funding the public
schools
um would
operate if adopted and if operating
according to our
expectations uh
to move towards an equitable position
for all kids and P particularly those
kids that are living in property poor
school districts and who themselves come
from a property poor not a property an
income poor right household right no
thanks thanks very much for the uh for
the question I'm going to try to see if
if uh if the chair will allow me to use
a prop I'm not sure I can find it in
time um but um but well so here's
one are you are you referencing the yeah
I'm referencing report commission
reports
and yeah and so so yep yep so this is on
page
27 where where it shows um a correlation
of of a minus 89 which is a very strong
r value for for for correlation between
uh loow income and outcome Factor uh
scores so so you know how students
perform on test what I'm really looking
for is the there's a there's a bubble
chart in
here that talks about how the difference
in a in a targeted because this this is
what we're talking about here is is is
targeted school funding not one size
fits all target um um and and how how
how you you can take a look at one size
fits-all and see how all the bubbles are
it doesn't matter how how um for every
school district they're basically all
lined up lined up straight but in
targeted you can you can see that where
the where the where the student needs
are greater or where the access to
resources are less that that it it's
it's much more um it's less regressive
than it is um right now a lot less
regressive and New Hampshire has one of
I guess that's one of the other graphs
in here I might be able to find it I
think I just saw it on page
25 um it Compares New Hampshire with uh
with other states and um and it just
basically shows a line between um uh
relative spending and and um and uh
relative poverty so we're you know that
same graph U that we showed in other you
know on page 27 that that represent
fellow asked about and um and what um
what 772 does is shifts that um that
that line from a regressive line to
something much less aggressive and much
more Equitable and and if I can add on
on to this too what's what's other
states have looked at this obviously you
know States uh do it our neighboring
state Vermont uh did it as well and they
focused their attention on taxpayer
Equity so I think everybody in Vermont
pays $10 per thousand on their property
tax and so the state funds I mean it's
something like this and and the state
distributes those funds to fund um uh to
fund their public uh their Public
Schools but it doesn't base it on
student outcomes and doesn't
differentiate the fact that maybe kids
going to Rutland are are are maybe maybe
the challenges in Rutland are different
than the than the than the challenges in
um in Woodstock and um and and so what
772 does is it focuses on the student
outcomes first and when you focus on
student outcomes the taxpayer Equity
follows if it's fair for students it is
fair for taxpayers not not necessarily
the other way around and and I think
this is why it's too good an opportunity
for us we may not get to it this year
there's a lot in here um but but if
we're going to do something that's fair
for taxpayers and I think all of our all
of our um constituents want that then as
sure as heck should be fair for students
too um uh because we don't want to let
you know leave them on the side of the
road further questions from the
committee
yes thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question as we're talking
about this we're talking about fairness
and you had mentioned um that part is of
this is the state should be guaranteeing
the resources needed for um for our
schools and for our students and
thinking about that and listening to
newort saying that they can't compete
with salaries um you know I'm curious
should we o be considering the account
um the accountability of how money is
spent so what I mean by that is should
we be looking at doing some of the
contract negotiations some of the
supplier no
negotiations um consolidating some of
the saus uh purchasing more volume
discounts uh with more volume discounts
Manchester obviously can buy at a much
better rate than a a smaller School
District so if we're going to be looking
at making sure we're providing an
adequate education and the revenue wise
should we also be looking at taking on
some of those expenses leaving the towns
to just voting on their discretionary
expenses as was mentioned by my fellow
rep here yeah no that's a that's a
really good question um I I I know some
states do actually have I think a
uniform uh teachers contract or um uh
pay scale pay schedule uh for teachers
we don't in in New Hampshire I don't
know if something like that would work
in New Hampshire um and um and that may
be something that uh that that you know
we may want to we may want to look at I
think there's a bill in that's going to
seek to establish a commission to study
uh School District consolidation or SAU
consolidation I forget which I think
it's been heard already saus saus and
and that's something that I think we
should learn about
I you
know teacher you know Personnel salaries
I think are are somewhere you know 75 to
80% of a of a school district's budget
and and um you know purchasing materials
and toilet paper and stuff like that you
know I you know yeah I mean I suppose we
could have purchase agreements and and
and actually Hopkinson does have
purchase agreements with with other
school districts for some bulk items and
U and I think uh through the
I think through the LGC maybe there's
there's um um uh uh fuel uh purchasing
agreements too uh but I'd be going back
a bunch of years on that so so I think
some I think districts are doing that in
hopkington and Jerry F not here Sor can
I excuse me one second what's LGC The
Local Government Center thank you sorry
keep going and um and uh you know we
even I think partner with Hopkinson and
karge partnered uh with uh because we
both send kids to the to the CTC in
conquered for um for career technical
education and so the bus started in
karge and picked up the kids in
Hopkinton and then went to conquer so so
school districts are are collaborating
uh to uh to find ways saving saving
money whether that's through CTE and
transportation or purchasing agreements
or sports teams um uh they do work
together
thank you very much yes we have a
collaborative on our bus routes up there
in hail collaborative is with schools in
Vermont yeah so the bus lines are going
both sides of the river paid equally by
the two school districts Blue Mountain
and then uh April and you got a bridge
there too we have a bridge yeah yeah
there's G to be a toll in that bridge
pretty soon um I got a question for you
here uh you mentioned targeting versus
non-targeting and of course the left
hand side of our formula right now is
we're Bound By The Claremont London
decisions where all districts regardless
of their wealth or their poverty are
treated the same uh the right hand side
of our our our funding formulas tried to
Target money towards certain
groups uh this formula right
here where is there any problems here
that we may encounter with the clar
decisions regard to how we're now we're
targeting money towards specific
students so so thanks for that question
um uh just for the to to to uh to be
completely clear um uh representative
Ames um um former representative Mel
Miler Mary Heath and I uh are are filed
in a Mei brief with the court to present
that very
question and and uh and you know maybe
representative Ames um well I mean I
think this this is good work session
discussion too um but but I believe the
the the words in our Constitution use
the word guarantee
funding am I correct on
that I mean I'm sorry I'm not trying to
turn this into well I know that we had
this discussion with hardinger and uh
and we looked at the models down in
Massachusetts and there there's a
difference and we of course have these
court cases which are kind of
controlling what we have
done right right so so you know so I I
think you're right I mean I think I
think this this committee is going to be
very and I think the legislature is
going to be very interested in in what
um what the court comes back with on
particularly on conval but also on on
Rand and as you and I were talking about
it the other day too I I I I don't feel
that we should be reading too
prescriptively that that the court is
telling us what to do perhaps the court
is telling us what to do if the model
doesn't change if we're going to just be
doing the same one siiz fits-all um type
of way of funding um funding our schools
but if we're interested in looking at
something different I would hope been
far for me to tell tell a judge what to
do um but um um you get the joke right
hey don't you live with a judge yeah
there you go yeah so um but um but but
that that that maybe there would be and
this is the point of our of our amichi
brief that that that other models exist
that that that would depart from a
uniform one-size fits-all payoff
type of um type of um uh funding
mechanism and could do a much better job
for both New Hampshire students as well
as
taxpayers further questions represent
fellows thank you um I just I'm looking
at that second block you know where
where it has the requirements that from
the conval case and the last thing that
the state's responsible for is um
accountability to make sure that
districts have have provided an adequate
education and districts are doing that
based on the District budget so you have
to remember that I come from towns that
have a Cooperative School District so
the
municipalities are
not
responsible
for only the dist the um towns in a
co-op are only collectively responsible
for what they vote on for the District
budget so where how do
you
reconcile
calculations for a municipality with
districts yeah no thanks very much for
the question because that that's a
that's a really great great question um
currently accountability can also you
know and it's and it's accountability to
the to the state share that that comes
through through the adequacy grant um
that that as long as states are
operating within the parameters that are
defined in in statute or in rules that
that class size is below this number
that you've got one 1500th of a
principal for every student one 1500th
of a um of a u um uh of a uh school
counselor for every student I mean
that's accountability that that the what
what we add here is student performance
is student outcomes and the fact that
the foundation opportunity budgets are
calculated based on based on the the the
the all the based on a district
educating all of its students to a
Statewide outcome that uh that districts
can be held accountability can be held
accountable to that average and um and
yes there's there so there there's a
shift in how how the accountability
language in I'm not remembering all the
sections 198 H something like that
something like that um talks about
accountability and and that um and you
know we don't we you know I don't think
it talks about shutting down the school
but if if if a school district after a
certain number of years is not seeing
their their their average student
performing towards the Statewide average
that the Department of Education would
be giving them some
guidance pardon me yes so I'm thinking
if you have two two school districts and
number of kids in them are exactly the
same but one of them the students are
performing lower
because we won't go into why they're
they're performing well let's say
because um the income level in in the
town is lower than in the in the other
Town wouldn't that opportunity budget
for those two dist districts be
different they are okay they are the one
the one that if more resources yes so so
uh yes if you had two identical
districts um identical in every way
except uh District you know District B
has or you know one of the districts has
uh has a substantially higher you know
number of students that come from
low-income backgrounds that District
would have a higher Foundation
opportunity budget than the other one
yes other questions
yes I I'm intrigued by this whole thing
because I when we talk about wind them
um and let's look at Penbrook if say for
instance wiam is performing and and they
have a marching band they have things in
their program that they can actually be
for can we look at this and say penberg
needs a marching band as well so that
there there becomes equality of of what
districts are offering and especially in
terms of the amount of money that's
being offered faculty because there's a
huge sure sure um yeah I you you you can
count on that there there are some
things that some um and we've got a
whole we've got a whole discussion brief
on the school funding website on talking
about um um some costs that that that
don't have the same type of efficiency
um to them and there are some there are
some um but um but a lot of things like
whether it's a school ban or a football
team or or you know a spirit team or
something like that I mean or or a first
robotics team I mean you know these are
all these are all part of the reasons
why why kids show up to school in the
morning right because they sign up they
signed the co-curricular agreement
saying you know what if you don't come
to school that day you don't come to
practice you don't come to practice you
don't play right yeah yeah and so it
gets the school it gets the kids in the
door and and that's a big I'm not I
don't have a a teacher background I
think there's there's a lot folks in
here that do but that's a big part of
the battle right getting the kids in the
door and then you can do
something yeah in terms of this bill um
how how are the how are the marching
band schools and the the theater program
schools how are they differentiated in
in any way in what's being funded that's
all that's all part of the
calculation you know if if wendam has
them and and Pa doesn't then then then
then and and and windom's student
outcomes are higher than Pas there'll
there'll be things that are attributed
student outcomes will be attributed to
the fact that it offers those programs
PA's budget Foundation opportunity
budget would include programs necessary
to bring those students up but it would
really be to the the um the um the the
professional guidance of your building
principles your superintendent and your
teachers um with which to know what sort
of programs to and I keep looking over
at Tracy because she's on a school board
and as a teacher um you know to make a
to make a professional determination um
as as to what to what to offer and and
like I mentioned in the accountability
section if you're not getting the
results after a certain number of years
the department will give you some
guidance on um on on you know maybe you
know take a look at what Windam is doing
and um do a little bit more of
that further questions from the
committee thank you very much great
thank you very much Mr
chair
me yeah um that that came from Dr and Dr
sitting right to your right
Bruce um Bruce do you have a moment to I
I I noticed within that report there's
some issues dealing with the swep and in
forms and all that can you talk about
that a little bit what you you indicated
if the local is going to collect come on
up so I don't have to go across the room
and
talk as technical support I was going to
ask for this um the local municipality
collects the
swep the swep is then returned or sent
to the the
state
the in this
bill everything is sent to the treasury
yeah that's what I'm saying to the
treasury yeah in this
bill and within that we used to have
various form forms which were created by
at that time I don't know if was Dr or
the commissioner of Ed for the process
for funneling this stuff back to the
treasur um and have you addressed that
at all in this report that you have here
you gave
us very briefly it was addressed I mean
the model for what you're
describing I'll get a little close
yeah I believe the uh the quick guide
note was meant to um state that
examining some very old records gives us
an idea of how that would be
accomplished um forms
really stopped being used for that
purpose I believe around 2003 might have
been the last year so we have a few
archived examples of how it took place
then what this bill is describing looks
to be similar to that in terms of uh the
relationship between swept taxes being
raised and then uh sent to the state
so um I hope that can address that's
about all I can say at this point
because um it hasn't been something
that's been used for a very very long
time but it doesn't look I I I I've seen
it back in those years but I thought it
came up closer like to 2011 or
so uh when when the districts were
allowed to municipalities allowed to
keep the excess rather than having to
return it back and have have to do some
more
research you don't have to go
researching that are there any other
technical questions for yes
representative Earth I hope this is an
easy one is this note and your others
available
online um attorney Ramsey indicated to
me when I was back at Dr that they were
hoping to have the quick guides up on
the website this afternoon okay can you
let us know where that
is where we're on the website yeah we're
on the website soon as I learned that I
could uh I don't
know okay I mean it be very helpful to
actually maybe have even tied into the
bill as it reports out of the legisl so
we had links to it from here from the
from the legislative website all right I
will let her know that uh there is that
desire Jennifer is that something we
could do is have you know a link design
SC she's our researcher and our attorney
that works with is is the possible to
link through that and we could link
right in that way when we go look at
this bill
I think the closest that we could come
to that is it was sub
testimony yeah I think we could also
work through the LBA they have a website
if you just knew where the heck they
were
okay yes represent fellows yes um can
you just you you know I haven't had a
chance to read what you handed out can
you just um tell us
briefly um about the equalization
process and how that's
impacting the irregularities of in the
state property tax rates there there was
an article in the um union leader not
this Sunday but the one before about how
it's impacting towns because it's only
done every five years can you talk just
a little
bit actually representative fellows very
little because it's not an area of
specialty for me um I think you'd
probably the committee probably need to
hear from someone like assistant
director danan core to speak to the
intricacies of
Equalization and what you're describing
I'm afraid I just don't participate in
that aspect of the
work represent Ames
good to see you
again sir and this
is just to note well first I very much
appreciate the hard work that you and or
your staff did in trying to get your
head around the various confusing
aspects of this bill um very much
appreciate that and um having been
confused by many dimensions of it over
many years um I can
uh sympathize empathize with that effort
um and uh I know that in this note I
read it very quickly first thing this
morning I think
um you identified Dr identified
some some apparent uh circular
secularity of uh relationships between
uh Concepts and so forth um and all I
want to say right now is thank you and
we'll work on it and see
if we agree that there's stuff there
that needs to be fixed and we'll fix it
and I when I say we i' been working
closely with representative luno and and
Bill ardinger outside of these Halls um
we we'll get it right and it's it's just
techn stuff ultimately just needs to get
the concepts are right just need to get
uh make sure it's right in the eyes of
those that have to manage it which is
the
Dr representative Ames the most
important thing from my perspective
about the bill is really laying out a
timeline to see when which
agency or entity is expected to do
something and then contrast that with
the timeline line that you know is is
well established and that's where that
question of and I can say for a fact I
mean at
currently our entire annual process of
setting a property tax rate drives
toward toward One Moment In Time when
the rates are established and there's
nothing in that set of calculations that
in envisioned any kind of
comparison that's the circularity of
establish a rate compare it possibly
have to adjust it before finalizing
it um but a timeline begins to help us
understand if we can accommodate that or
if deadlines have to be requested to be
changed um and I look forward again to
working with uh everybody knows mark at
education as we sort of sit down and
combine our timelines and make certain
that what he needs or education needs we
can supply in a timely fashion and vice
versa well excellent and thank you
again um any further questions by what
index or how you're there
363 million for the
swep do we've had it constant we haven't
changed that we haven't gone with CPI or
whatever no how would that be done and
this bill it's it's not going to remain
constant at 363 I would assume it's
going to have to
grow the the the calculations we could
call this a Back to the Future moment uh
it'll it'll it will be something like it
was in 1999 and the succeeding I think
three or four years there's a rate we'll
get the equalized values from the
equalization Z compile them we have a
total we'll apply that uh 250 per th000
rate we'll extend that and develop a
dollar amount for every
municipality and that will become the
the swept
warrant um and which is exactly what I I
wasn't there but I'm I'm pretty certain
that's what was done those first few
years although the legislature
was matting down the rate Year bye in
those first five
years but in regard to the 363 that's
been a constant number 2005 for a long
time 2005 is is the first year it was in
place it'll always be slightly higher
than 363 million um by law we get to use
a half penny on that rate which is why
it looks so strange the Statewide rate
uh just to make sure it's not a
complicated set of iterations I just I
literally do it myself it just takes one
or two tries till we have the half penny
that gets it over the $363 million mark
thank you for the questions of the
department yes represent fellow it's not
a question but I just wanted to um thank
Bruce for identifying that 2003 was the
last time that we actually sent property
tax the swept money back to the state
because I had asked uh Dr last year and
the only thing they and and somebody did
a lot of research the only thing he
could say was that it was sometime
before 2005 and I can confirm that there
was nothing since 2005 because I was
involved with that the whole time and
you can go to the Department of
education's website and look at adequacy
Aid descriptions way back to 2004 and
see that there was no mention of the
swep going to the state further
questions of the department thank you
very very much I have a card here from
Deborah
house good afternoon chairman lad it's
good to be here with the education
funding committee and uh I will be brief
because I do not have a whole lot of
Statistics to give you today um my name
is Deborah H I am president of the
American Federation of teachers New
Hampshire I'm here on behalf of our 3500
members who are mostly in prek through
12 public education as well as as uh
higher education to support the uh big
idea behind this bill we know that we
need a stable
predictable um and effective way to fund
our Public Schools it is a
constitutional right for all of our
grand State children to have a robust
public education and the system we have
right now just is not managing to do
that in a way that is fair to all of our
students and fair to our local property
taxpayers I think we're increasingly
seeing that um if you're not seeing it
now you will um come toown meeting time
or come toown meeting time next year uh
you know it's been a squeeze everywhere
but we want to be fair both to the
students and to the property taxpayers
um our students deserve to have small
class sizes they deserve to have
professional certified and well-trained
teachers who are capable of
differentiating lessons for students
with um specialized education needs as
well as um for students with English
language learning needs um they deserve
support from par Educators they deserve
a full range of academic subjects and
challenging curriculum so you it would
be great to have parching B and but also
would be really great to have uh
calculus taught by a live instructor
instructor who can maybe differentiate a
lesson if you are one of those um double
doubly exceptional students who has both
um you know bright intellect but a
learning disability so all of our
students deserve that and this is a
different way of looking at funding it
which is why we're excited about it um
particularly part where it calculates
the foundation opportunity on the actual
cost of achieving um you know that go
into running the school and achieving
the student outcomes because we know
that performance on our assessment
measures measures which are Statewide
assessments vary greatly and that mostly
correlates with whether your school is
well funded and that correlates whether
you're a property poor or property Rich
District you'll always have some
students who do well in any school we've
always got some high performers but the
ones who struggle are the ones who are
in classes that don't get a lot of
attention because they're overcrowded
who don't necessarily come in with the
best foundation because maybe they come
from families where Mom and Dad are both
working there's not someone at home uh
who can pay a lot of attention to them
all the time and provide them with
enriching
activities um if you're not coming in
with a lot of background or have a lot
of enriching activity outside of school
you're coming in with a deficit and if
you don't have a lot of individual
attention in school the deficit just
grows larger and larger this gives
opportunity for schools
to provide the support that Learners
need without breaking the back of local
property taxpayers who are already
overburdened so that's why we're excited
about it uh as far as the nape scores go
our gorgia New Hampshire are not
necessarily as high as we wanted to be
but they
are better they are better than much of
the country they are
um they are showing Improvement they're
moving in the right direction so we are
on the right track we are not showing
equal Improvement in all districts which
is why is important to get get this
right and one other thing I I would like
to um share with you
is a very recent just came out yesterday
review of uh scholar research that does
indeed show once again that funding
matters in K12 education increasing K12
funding improves student outcomes and
funding cuts hurt those outcomes this
was an overview of scholarly research
done by the Albert Shanker Institute and
I will send you a link to the report um
New Hampshire overall if we just look at
an average does well but that's because
our local property taxpayers carry so
much of the burden and that is
unsustainable the opportunity to fix it
with something like this blueprint is
really something all of our students
deserve and I hope that you find a way
to make it work and pass this thank you
very much I appreciate your thank you
are there questions from the
committee I hope I can answer represent
fellows yeah so I wonder if you could go
over the um
the points that you think are
contributing factors to low performance
of a student and and also um do you
think that students that they tend to be
in the low income category that move a
lot from one District to
another um how that contributes to low
performance maybe moving from one school
to another within a district or from one
District to another definitely create
um creates or widens gaps in learning
because they will miss part of the
curriculum um they it takes time to
adjust to new school so there's the
whole social adjustment uh emotional
adjustment just getting used to being in
a new place getting used to new people
um even if you're an outgoing child
that's still going to take a little time
um but you will have missed some some
lessons in a curriculum you'll either be
ahead of something even in the same
district or you'll be behind so you've
lost some learning time if you are not
an average or above average learner you
will be out of place and need even more
support to catch up if you're an above
average learn you might be bored and and
then there could be some behavior issues
if you're you know acting out because
you're bored and you're doing you've got
work to do that you already did and
you'd rather be doing something else or
um so there's all sorts of things that
can go on uh but yeah that does create a
lot of gaps the more often a student
moves um the worse impact it has on
their academic outcomes now I I know
there are some who who do manage to take
it in stride but that generally is with
a good amount of family support uh and
school support So if it's a planned move
uh you can um lessen some of the impacts
but it does have an impact and I oh
there was another question about some
other factors
um
certainly um being from a being part of
a family that's living in
poverty often has an impact because of
not necessarily having the supports that
you need outside of school if your
family moving frequently could be part
of that um you know if a family doesn't
have stable housing um
also if you have a situation where all
of the adults are working they they're
working Ser serially like mom works one
shift dad works another shift and
there's maybe not a lot of adult time
spent with a child
in fun enriching activities a lot of
conversation going on building up that
vocabulary
um you know just just the the whole
knowledge of words and conversation that
um you would love to be able to have but
if if the family's just trying to make
sure there's enough income coming in uh
to pay the bills and everyone's working
as hard as they can you don't
necessarily have time to have good long
conversations and read lots of books
with your children and no judgment here
honest um but a child comes in with the
deficit of receptive language with a
deficit in reading and it takes longer
to learn those skills once you get in
school so you come in already behind and
um you can you know close that Gap some
but it takes more people working with
that child in
school yeah any further further
questions thank you very much
welcome I don't have any other pin cards
up here on this bill right now so I'm
going to close this hearing
Friday um Thursday Thursday is a session
dat do you have any word on if they
think they might cancel it due to the
weather I have I can't I don't have a
crystal ball but we have discussed it
and I do not see them canceling this
session at
all this is from georget University
if it's just three inches or four inches
of snow make sure you got your snow
tires on because you're
driving e